sprachlich völlig okay dass die
bundesregierung an diesem donnerstag in
den bundestag einbringen das sogenannte
oster paket und in diesem roster paket
stecken drei gesetzentwürfe die sich
beschäftigen mit dem schnelleren ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien dass das
dringend nötig ist wissen wir es gibt
viele gute gründe dafür da voranzukommen
die frage ist nur ob die schönen pläne
aller auch aufgehen darüber wird der
bundestag gleich gut 70 minuten 75
minuten diskutieren ab 9 wir tun das
jetzt schon mal und ich freue mich dass
heute morgen bei uns sind nina scheer
die klimaschutz und energiepolitische
sprecherin der spd-fraktion und andreas
jung ist bei uns in derselben funktion
in der unions fraktion tätig guten
morgen ihnen beiden schön dass sie da
sind
der wirtschaftsminister habe spricht von
der wisag der größten energiepolitischen
gesetzesnovelle seit jahrzehnten in
einer hinsicht recht israel
gesetzentwürfe sind fast 600 seiten
stark was den umfang angeht habe ich
gelesen was frau her ist aus ihrer sicht
der entscheidende punkt unter ziemlich
vielen die wir jetzt alle auflisten
könnten der entscheidende punkt ist dass
wir die vielen sich angestaut haben denn
hemmnisse bei der energiewende die auch
regulativ sind also auch in den gesetzen
verankert sind dass diese abgebaut
werden und dass wir auch von den
ausgegangenen mengen die wir an strom
brauchen für zwanzig dreißig dass wir da
eine anpassung vornehmen weil wir im
jahr 2030 deutlich mehr strom brauchen
wären alleine mit blick auf die
verkehrswende auf die wärme wende die
sehr viel mehr strom enthalten wird wenn
man davon immer zu niedrigen zahlen
ausgeht und davon wiederum einen anteil
erneuerbarer energien erreichen möchte
der dann auch noch zu niedrig angesetzt
ist wie es in der vergangenheit immer
waren dann brauchen wir uns nicht zu
wundern wenn die ausbau mengen die
förderinstrumente und alles was da dran
hängt immer zu wenig waren in der
vergangenheit dann kamen noch weitere
hemmnisse administrativer art dazu wir
wollen hier mit einem großen kraftakt
diese ganzen hemmnisse diese ganzen die
beschleunigung hemmenden faktoren
beseitigen um so ein bisschen
plastischer zu machen sagen sie ein
konkretes beispiel für die hemmnisse die
sie jetzt wiederholt er haben wir wissen
zum beispiel dass bei der windenergie
gerade wenn es um die akteure landwirte
kommunen bürgerinnen und bürger die
kleineren akteure gingen dass die sehr
schwer nur anteil haben konnten am
ausbau erneuerbarer weil sie zum
beispiel nicht so einfach an den
ausschreibungen teilnehmen konnten wir
werden jetzt erleichtern auch für bürger
energiegesellschaften dass sie außerhalb
von ausschreibungs angeboten einfach
ohne großen administrativen drum herum
da jetzt in die in die beteiligung
einsteigen können der union herr jung
insbesondere ihren wirtschaftsminister
altmaier aus der letzten
legislaturperiode ist oft vorgeworfen
die energiewende verschleppt zu haben
insbesondere den ausbau was winter
energie angeht sie selber sind
bekanntermaßen ein befürworter eines
schnelleren ausbaus wie viel zustimmung
haben sie für diese drei für dieses
poster paket ich kann erst mal das was
vorher gerade gesagt hätte teilen es
geht in der tat darum jetzt den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien zu
beschleunigen es geht darum hemmnisse
abzubauen
wo dafür vorschläge gemacht werden da
werden wir die mittragen wir erkennen
nur in diesem paket das auch neue hürden
aufgebaut werden sollen denn zwei
beispiele es soll gedeckelt werden
die biomethan einspeisung in das gasnetz
gerade jetzt ist es aber doch wichtig
dass wir in biogasanlagen
produzierte energie in das gasnetz
einspeisen können weil wir doch alles
brauchen um russische energie zu
ersetzen dass es einen neuen deckel
geben das können wir nicht verstehen das
werden wir kritisieren in diesem
verfahren nicht noch ein zweites
beispiel ich hätte meine frage weil sie
ja auch gesagt haben es hat daher oder
die hemmnisse wie auch beschrieben haben
die frau schon erwähnt hat warum haben
sie wenig letzten legislaturperiode
schon abgeschafft das einlegen hat eine
frage mit der wir uns auseinandersetzen
die richtet sich an alle ein
wesentlicher vorschlag ist er ist ein
neuer vorschlag um erneuerbare energien
und artenschutz zusammenzubringen da
haben in der tat schon in der letzten
legislaturperiode die umweltminister
aller länder über jahre traten ohne ein
ergebnis zu haben das ist übrigens eine
ministerin der union dabei gewesen und
11 der grün und ein paar andere das
heißt die frage ist berechtigt mit der
müssen sich alle beschäftigen geht es
darum dass wir ein möglichst breites
bündnis ein möglichst breiten
schulterschluss haben um gemeinsam voran
zu gehen und da erwarten wir auch vom
bundeswirtschaftsminister dass seine
reise durch die bundesländer jetzt nicht
folgenlos bleibt sind es auch
verhandlungen gibt mit den ländern um
gemeinsam zu einem ergebnis zu kommen
das darf nicht einfach vom bund aus
verordnet werden es muss gemeinsam
entwickelten in bayern ist ja schon mal
gewesen und da seht ihr ein kleines
bisschen so aus als wenn er ja auch ein
kleines bisschen da offenbar bewegt hat
beispielsweise was die entfernung angeht
von windrädern von sie von siedlungen
frau schöne gesetz ich gebe mich bietet
ihnen eine frage an die gesetze sind das
eine in der überleitung auch schon
gesagt irgendwie die frage ist ja lässt
sich das alles so umsetzen wo sind sie
denn die größten gehören im moment noch
darf ich noch mal ganz kurz auf die
jahren eingehen weil das wir hier
irgendwo bei den erneuerbaren bei
welcher auch immer deckeln würden das
halte ich für ein grobes gerücht was
jetzt noch alles weitere aber wir sind
im parlamentarischen verfahren ab heute
und wenn die entwürfe deckelungen
enthalten dann ist das jedenfalls nicht
in unserem sinne deswegen müssen wir
schauen dass wir das im einklang mit
allen rahmenbedingungen die wir auch
europarechtlich zu beurteilen haben und
zu bewerten einzubeziehen haben das
hinkriegen aber dass eine deckelung der
erneuerbaren am ende rauskommt das ist
nicht unser plan ihn bei der bioenergie
muss man aber zudem auch darauf achten
dass man sie möglichst verbessert
einsetzt ja deswegen dass man
veränderungen vornimmt ist so sehr wohl
sinnvoll weil man eben teilweise die
wertvolle bioenergie so eingesetzt hat
dass sie nicht ihren ihren charakter der
das allseits verfügbaren und
einsetzbaren auch als regelenergie
einsetzbar wenn man keinen wind hat
keine sonne hat dass man sich gezielt
dort einsetzt und nicht einfach nur
stumpf verstromung dass man eben diesen
charakter der bioenergie besser
aufgreifen kann und dass man das auch
gesetzlich
stichwort flexibilisierung da auch mit
einbezieht aber bei windenergie was
haben wir da jetzt schon erreicht
unfalls von wegen was heißt mitnehmen
der länder es gibt auch einen
entwurf aus eine formulierungshilfe die
uns schon im parlament erreicht hat die
aber jetzt heute nicht eingebracht wird
was wir sehr bedauerlich finden dass man
auch diese leider in der letzten
koalition
eingebrachten 1000 meter abstand
möglichkeiten von windenergie zu
gebäuden ja die länder haben eine
möglichkeit bekommen diese 1000 meter
fix zu definieren das ist natürlich auch
ein hemmnis ja wir hätten es gerne
gehabt dass man diese 1000 meter wieder
beseitigt also dass man diese
möglichkeit diese abstände wieder
beseitigt weil die bundesländer ebenda
so fixe abstände machen können bayern
hat jetzt nicht einfach die 10h regelung
also diese zehn mal die höhe der
windkraftanlagen
regelungen abgeschafft sondern hat sich
auf diese 1000 meter regelung jetzt
nochmal bezogen also auch da haben wir
leider ein signal von länderseite dass
man nicht überall gewillt ist nicht
überall gewählt ist tatsächlich auch
solche abstände zu verzichten wir
brauchen wenn wir einen solchen konsens
wollen in den ländern da brauchen wir da
mehr bereitschaft auf länderseite dass
man auch pauschale abstandsregelung
verzichtet sonst muss einfach eine
bundesregelung her die solche pauschalen
abstände vermeidet soll ich kommen wir
nicht weit herr jung gerne direkt dazu
ich finde was wir brauchen ist eine
vereinbarung von bund und ländern wo man
sich verständigt über die ziele was
müssen wir erreichen wie viel strom
produktion wie viel energie wie viel
wärme brauchen wir aus erneuerbaren
energien da sollten sich die länder dazu
kommen dafür ist die bereitschaft auch
da und der weg wie es dann in den
einzelnen ländern erreicht wird da haben
wir föderale vielfalt die gilt es auch
zu berücksichtigen da brauchen wir auch
die regionen die ganzen planungsprozesse
machen die regionalverbände deshalb
wünschen wir uns dass in diesem prozess
die regionalplanung gestärkt wird weil
sie die möglichkeit bietet die ziele
verbindlich festzuschreiben und
gleichzeitig ausgleich zu schaffen mit
anderen belangen und das müssen wir
hinbekommen
die erreichung und akzeptanz haben sie
ja im vorfeld kritisiert dass der bund
zu viele vorgaben macht statt auch sich
im vorfeld schon mal mit den ländern zu
reden auf der anderen seite muss man ja
doch wahrscheinlich sagen ohne vorgaben
würde sich überhaupt nichts bewegen wir
müssen ja nur in die vergangenen jahre
zurück
ich hätte ja gerade beschrieben dass es
richtig ist dass die umweltminister in
ihren beratungen alleine nicht zu einem
ergebnis gekommen sind müssen jetzt alle
ein großer bunter vorgabe wenn man da
geht es um wind und sonne bei der sonne
wünschen wir uns dass neben dem es im
eeg geregelt wird ist eine ganz einfache
botschaft gibt nämlich dass es für die
privaten dachanlagen steuerfreiheit gibt
es ist ein anderes zu machen es sind
beitrag zum bürokratieabbau es gibt
einen vorschlag dazu auch aus dem
bundesrat um wirklich da ein boom
einschub eine freude auch zu erhalten
und auszulösen und eine bemerkung ein
zweiter deckel wird gemacht bei der
wasserkraft in dem oster paket ist das
vdi wasserkraft da wird ein deckel
eingezogen eine modernisierungs deckel
das halten wir schon fehler wir brauchen
die ganze seite und da gehört auch die
wasser kräfte zu erfahren was
die erneuerbaren bekommen das ist klar
und es ist auch in der tat so wir
brauchen die vereinfachung gerade bei
der photovoltaik bei denen das hatte ich
ganz zu anfang ja schon gesagt bei all
dem was die bürgerinnen und bürger
sofort machen können da gibt es viel zu
viele hemmnisse ist dauert heutzutage
teilweise länger eine schon installierte
photovoltaikanlage abgenommen zu
bekommen als sie zu installiert auch
dass ein hemmnis was nicht sein muss
diese vereinfachen brauchen wir aber
auch da muss man ich will jetzt nicht
nach in die vergangenheit treten noch
mal aber leider dafür haben wir auch
hemmnisse aufgebaut in den letzten
jahren die jetzt muss ich wieder abbauen
müssen und ich möchte nur davor warnen
zu lange sich nur auf runde tische zu
verlassen wir brauchen auch an manchen
stellen klärungen definitionen damit man
verlässlichkeit hat rechtssicherheit hat
dass auch die länder sich an etwas
orientieren können um was die länder
brauchen ist unterstützung auch bei der
personellen bewältigung in den behörden
da haben wir glaube ich alle seine
verantwortung dass das keine jahre
langen genehmigungsverfahren gibt es
kann nicht sein dass eine
windkraftanlage mehrere jahre in der
genehmigungs schleife hängt da müssen
wir beschleunigt vorankommen und da
helfen dann irgendwann auch nur noch
begrenzt runde tische es muss das ziel
klar sein wir müssen hier tatsächlich
die den ausbau der erneuerbaren bei der
photovoltaik vervielfachen weil der
windenergie haben wir zur zeit auch ein
stagnieren dadurch dass wir zwar
ausbauen es werden weitere genehmigungen
erteilt aber zugleich werden ja auch
anlagen stillgelegt und das hält sich
teilweise zurzeit die waage oder ist
sogar rückläufig perspektivisches darf
nicht sein wir brauchen auch eine
deutliche vereinfachung für das
repowering also wird den ersatz alter
anlagen durch neue und darf nicht
kompliziert in neue
genehmigungsverfahren gehen das muss
eine selbstverständlichkeit sein das
repowering anzugehen die junge norma
dazu ist von unten tischen gar nicht
gesprochen sind von echten verhandlungen
die reise und die gespräche sind das
eine das andere ist dass man sich
verständigt dass sie auch ein prozess
der geht ja über jahrzehnte diese
bundesregierung ist für vier jahre im
amt aber dieser prozess wird länger
gehen der lösung einbezogen werden da
werden die regionen mehr rolle spielen
und deshalb muss verhandelt werden dass
man sich gemeinsam auf grundlegende ziel
auf instrumente am besten dann auch
gemeinsam auf gesetze verständigt da
brauchen wir keinen runden tisch wir
brauchen echte verhandlungen wo man
zusammensitzt und gemeinsam in der sache
regel die erneuerbaren möchten wir 2030
zu 80 prozent ausgebaut und das muss sie
das tor sind keine jahrzehnte sondern
das sind jetzt nur noch acht jahre und
80 prozent von ungefähr
750 terawattstunden sind ungefähr so
viel wie wenn wir das heutige den
heutigen strombedarf von 100 prozent
erneuerbar hätten wir haben der flasche
selbst nichts erzählte sondern
ja selbst acht jahre gehen über die
amtszeit dieser regierung hinaus und für
die gibt es keinen bestandsschutz diesem
gesetzespaket und deshalb wäre es gut
wenn wir so wie wir es hier debattieren
miteinander sprechen ich begrüße sehr
dass forscher sagt es ist die grundlage
und wo es dicke in diesem gesetz gibt
können wir die gemeinsam abräumen ich
habe befürchtet dass wir hier natürlich
nur ansatzweise das erörtern können
worum es geht weil das natürlich wie
üblich alles viel komplizierter ist als
man sich vorstellen kann teufel steckt
ganz häufig im detail ich habe eine
frage die ich unbedingt noch loswerden
will erneuerbare energien sind das eine
auf der anderen seite frage ich mich
warum in diesen zeiten wo energie immer
teurer wird warum das thema energie
sparen nicht größer gemacht wird warum
es keine kampagne gibt und zwar nicht im
hinblick zu sagen zieht euch hier im
winter ein pullover mehr an sondern
einfach richtig sinnvoll selbst der adac
sagt inzwischen seinen
vereinsmitgliedern
zum bäcker irgendwie oder kombiniert
meinetwegen fahrten warum kommt ja aus
der politik ist das recht in
anführungszeichen warum kommt in dem
feld da einfach so wenig und das war das
einfachste und das günstigste und
sinnvoll in vielerlei hinsicht noch
einiges kommen also das dann wird es
auch informationskampagnen geben da bin
ich zuversichtlich dass da noch mehr
kommt und man muss eben einfach schauen
dass das auch ein solidarpakt ist es
darf nicht die kommunikation entstehen
fürs sparen sind jetzt einige wenige
zuständig auf der anderen seite wird
noch energie geprasst sondern das müssen
möglichst maßnahmen sein die in die
solidarisch von allen gleichermaßen eine
relative beeinflussung benachteiligung
einzelner gruppen stattfinden das ist
eine ganz wichtige angelegenheit beim
sparen aber natürlich wir haben enorme
einsparpotenziale auch solche die viele
menschen gar nicht so kennen deswegen
ist die information darüber immens
wichtig allein im gasbereich schätzt man
dass man ungefähr zehn prozent einsparen
könnte durch relativ einfache maßnahmen
das muss man ganz kurze antwort schaffen
doch teile des umfrage deshalb wo ist
endlich der energie sportlern der
bundesregierung wo ist die groß
angelegte kampagne für gas sparen wo ist
ein förderprogramm für
heizungsoptimierung mit massenhaft
gemacht wird kann es einen wichtigen
beitrag leisten wo sind die vorschläge
der bundesregierung wie in italien in
öffentlichen gebäuden energie zu sparen
alles was wir jetzt sparen können wir
speichern und hilft im winter und jetzt
ist genau so aus wie meine werke keinen
sommer reingehen aber es ist klar dass
zur nächsten heizperiode eine solche
planung angekommen sein muss und das ist
allen klar auf der bundesregierung jetzt
mal ganz fix aufhören weil die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas schon
an ihrem platz ich hatte gehofft wie sie
früher rein lassen zu können aber da
würden wir es so interessant vielen dank
frau scherer vielen dank herr jung und
ich gebe ganz fix rannten
nachträglich zu seinem sechzigsten
geburtstag
im namen des ganzen hauses wünsche ich
ihnen einen schönen tag hoffentlich
heute noch
willkommen zur tagesordnung
tagesordnungspunkt 30 wird abgesetzt an
dieser stelle soll tagesordnungspunkt 21
aufgerufen werden dazu sehe ich keinen
widerspruch
dann ist das so beschlossen ich rufe auf
die tagesordnungspunkte 7a bis 7 c sowie
zusatzpunkt zwei jeweils erste beratung
der von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten gesetzentwürfe zu
sofortmaßnahmen für einen beschleunigten
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
weiterer maßnahmen im stromsektor zur
änderung des windenergie auf see
gesetzes und anderer vorschriften
sowie zur änderung des
energiewirtschaftsgesetzes
sofortprogramm und zur anpassung im
recht der endkunden belieferung und
erste beratung des von den fraktionen
spd bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
beschleunigung des einsatzes
verflüssigten erdgases
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen ich eröffne
hiermit die aussprache das wort hat der
bundesminister dr robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
guten morgen lassen sie mich kurz mit
einem aktuellen ereignis anfangen des
dann abend ungefähr 22 uhr 30 hat putin
ein dekret veröffentlicht wonach
europäische gasversorger jetzt von
russland sanktioniert werden in
deutschland ist gazprom und ihre töchter
betroffen das heißt einige der
tochterunternehmen bekommen jetzt kein
gas mehr aus russland
aber der markt bietet andere
alternativen sie versorgen sich auf dem
markt mit anderen gas vier monitoren die
situation genau wir haben uns auf
situation vorbereitet und ich werde sie
dann im laufe des tages beziehungsweise
die bundesnetzagentur
informieren aber die situation ist so
dass der gasmarkt den gasaustritt aus
russland kommt kompensieren kann sehr
geehrte damen und herren ist zeigt also
dass die auseinandersetzung um energie
eine waffe ist und dass energie in einem
wirtschafts konflikt hat eingesetzt
werden kann insofern sind all die
anstrengungen die wir im moment
unternehmen und unternehmen müssen um
die versorgungssicherheit in deutschland
zu gewährleisten nicht das gegenteil
dessen was wir jetzt gleich diskutieren
sondern die voraussetzung dafür dass wir
in zukunft energie sicher sind ist der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien es gibt
eine
direkte
es gibt eine direkte linie von dem
abschied von fossilen energien aus
russland hin zum abschied der von
fossilen energien insgesamt und das
bedeutet ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien das vorgelegte paket ist die
größte energiemarkt reform seit jahren
ich würde sagen seit jahrzehnten es ist
ein paket das verschiedene gesetze
zusammen nimmt das wichtigste und das
größte ist das aber auch dass wind auf
sie gesetzt und die in wie die novelle
gehören dazu es ist eine fundamentale
neuausrichtung des gesamten energie
sektors auf treibhaus neutralität und
auch die ist dringend geboten bei allem
was uns in europa und in deutschland im
moment mit blick auf die russischen
lieferungen bedrückt wir dürfen den
blick auf den großen horizont nicht
studieren die un hat vor einigen tagen
gesagt dass mit einer großen
wahrscheinlichkeit in den nächsten fünf
jahren das 1,5 grad ziel überschritten
wird vielleicht noch nicht dauerhaft
aber dieses vielleicht hängt ganz
maßgeblich vom menschlichen tunap von
politischen entscheidungen dh die zeit
läuft uns davon sie läuft uns
buchstäblich davon und der krieg und die
toten im krieg in der ukraine das ist
schlimm und das ist furchtbar aber sie
werden mitbekommen haben dass an anderen
stellen der erde ernteausfälle hungernot
katastrophen drohen weil die tiere sich
in einem dramatischen ausmaß erhitzt wir
haben die chance dagegen an zu arbeiten
und wir tun ist mit diesem gesetzespaket
das wir heute vorliegt
das gesetzespaket setzt die ziele die
die alte bundesregierung schon
beschlossen hat um in konkrete maßnahmen
und die diese bundesregierung übernommen
hat wir werden die
treibhausgasemissionen damit 2030 um 65
prozent sinken und 2040 und - 80% wir
werden die stromerzeugung erneuerbare
energien damit 2030 auf 80 prozent auf
80 prozent anheben und dann in der mitte
der 30er jahre im strombereich die
treibhaus neutralität erreichen können
wir richten den netzausbau entsprechend
auf diese anforderung neu aus wir heben
die ausschreibungen menge auffinden wind
auf see also oft benutzten dafür neue
instrumente instrumente die noch nicht
ausgewiesene flächen ebenfalls in die
ausschreibung geben so dass damit dann
die industrie die chance hat diesen
windstrom auch für die produktion von
wasserstoff verstärkt zu nutzen wir
sorgen außerdem dafür dass die
beteiligung der menschen in diesem land
an den erneuerbaren energien deutlich
gesteigert wird bürgerwindparks eigenen
stromverbrauch die möglichkeit der
kommunen an den windparks zu profitieren
all das wird deutlich angegeben so dass
die demokratisierung des energiesystems
die teilhabe der menschen am
energiesystem tatsächlich nochmal
deutlich angehoben und erweitert wird
bis an die grenze
und wo ich das
und wo ich die
zwischenrufe hier von ganz rechts höre
sie werden sie werden möglicherweise
könnten es interessant sie werden schon
leicht mitbekommen haben dass gestern
ein schwedisches unternehmen noch rollt
eine investitionsentscheidung von 45
milliarden zur batterieproduktion in
deutschland getroffen hat dieses
unternehmen hat europaweit gesucht wo
ist der beste standort und sie haben
sich für einen standort entschieden der
die höchste durchdringung mit
erneuerbaren energien hat sie haben sich
europaweit für den standort entschieden
wo die meisten erneuerbare energien
verfügbar sind das zeigt dass wir nicht
nur das klima schützen dass wir nicht
nur außen und sicherheitspolitische
souveränität gewinnen sondern wohlstand
und wertschöpfung arbeitsplätze und die
industrie der zukunft jetzt aufbauen wir
schaffen damit auch die zukunft für den
wohlstand in diesem land alles spricht
dafür mit großer geschwindigkeit mit
großer entschlossenheit jetzt den ausbau
der erneuerbaren und die klima politik
umzusetzen spielen da
pro beitrag der
bundeswirtschaftsminister
zu den drei gesetzentwürfen der
bundesregierung die hier heute zum
ersten mal beraten werden eben plenum
es geht darum erneuerbaren energien
erneuerbare energien schneller
auszubauen als das bislang in der fall
gewesen ist erster redner in der debatte
dazu jetzt andreas jung aus der
unionsfraktion
kollegen seitens der unionsfraktion
befürworten wir aus überzeugung und mit
nachdruck das ziel eines beschleunigten
ausbaus der erneuerbaren energien es ist
eine notwendige antwort auf die
klimakrise und es macht uns unabhängiger
von fossilen importen aus russland da
muss jetzt beherzt vorangegangen werden
energisch voran das ist unsere linie in
diesen beratungen
es geht uns dabei darum das was wir hier
tun in einen europäischen kontext zu
bringen auch mit globalen energie und
klima partnerschaften voranzubringen das
beherzte handeln hier in deutschland und
es bekenntnis zum internationalen
klimaschutz sind zwei seiten einer
medaille wir sollten immer im kopf haben
das was wir hier machen muss innovativ
sein muss welt fähig sein muss dazu
angelegt sein dass wir mit partnern
gemeinsam klimaschutz eine nachhaltige
energieversorgung voranbringen das ist
unser maßstab
der minister habe ich sie haben ein
umfassendes paket vorgelegt
das ziel hemmnisse abzubauen
unterstützen wir wir stellen aber fest
viel papier führt nicht automatisch zu
schnellen fortschritten wir stellen fest
dass sie einen starken schwerpunkt
setzen auf sonnenenergie und wind das
teilen wir die werden einen wichtigen
die werden den größten beitrag leisten
wir stellen aber auch fest dass es in
ihrem entwurf bei geothermie bei
biomasse und wasserkraft regelung gibt
die die potenziale auch dieser
erneuerbaren energien nicht ausnutzen
und deshalb ist unser anspruch in den
beratungen dazu kommen dass die
potenziale aller erneuerbaren energien
ausgeschöpft werden das bestehende
hemmnisse abgebaut werden und dass nicht
neue hürden eingezogen werden das nehmen
wir aber bei dieser vorlage war das ist
die grundsätzliche linie und dann will
ich ganz konkret sagen wo sind diese
hemmnisse wie sehen wir diese hemmnisse
es soll aus gründen die wir nicht
nachvollziehen können eine deckelung
geben zur einspeisung von biomethan in
kraft-wärme-kopplungsanlagen da bitte
ich die vertreter der koalition zu
erklären warum sie haben doch in vielen
reden hier und in der öffentlichkeit zu
recht gesagt wir müssen jetzt alles tun
um wegzukommen von russischem gas wir
müssen alles tun und das durch heimische
produktion zu ersetzen da haben wir eine
möglichkeit und die ausgerechnet soll es
in ihrem entwurf gedeckelt werden das
werden wir nicht methan
sie wollen einen deckel auch ein ziel
für modernisierungen bei der wasserkraft
wir sind der meinung dass auch die
wasserkraft mit ihren möglichkeiten
einen beitrag leisten muss das falsch
ist sie nachrangig zu behandeln dass es
falsch ist mit ihren vorschlägen zur
vergütung modernisierung zu verhindern
weil modernisierung nicht nur zu mehr
erneuerbaren energien sind auch zu
besseren bedingungen bei der
gewässerökologie führen sie machen einen
deckel in ihren vorschlägen bei der
wasserkraft die wasserkraft ist svd in
ihre muster paket das muss sich ändern
und so werden wir uns in den beratungen
einbringen
wir unterstützen ausdrücklich alle
vorschläge die dazu geeignet sind die
gerade wärmeproduktion durch geothermie
voranzubringen dabei auch akzeptanz zu
schaffen die
rahmenbedingungen zu verbessern da ist
jetzt im gesetz bereits schon länger
enthalten die ankündung es gibt
irgendwann eine degression ohne zu sagen
wann die kommen könnte da sind wir der
meinung da sollten wir es gemeinsam eine
initiative machen das konkretisieren
weil die unsicherheit wann könnte ist
unter welchen bedingungen die degression
geben das widerspricht der
planungssicherheit und deshalb müssen
wir auch der besser verankert
ausdrücklich unterstützen wir die
bemühungen die sonnenenergie zu nutzen
auf dächern auf parkplätzen auf
auf vielen flächen an gewerbeflächen
konnte sie uns flächen auch in der
doppelnutzung und nutzungskonflikte zu
vermeiden wir glauben aber dass das was
im erneuerbaren energien gesetz gemacht
wird ergänzt werden musste ich eine ganz
klare botschaft nämlich steuerfreiheit
für die kleinen pv anlagen bis zu einer
installierten leistung von 30 kw der mit
der letzten periode ein anfang gemacht
bis 10 kw es gibt eine
bundesratsinitiative des landes baden
württemberg vorgestellt von einem grünen
finanzminister die unterstützen wir das
wir ein ganz klare botschaft wer sich so
eine anlage auf das dach macht derzeit
keine steuern das ist eine ermunterung
für den ausbau an aber energien ist ein
abbau von bürokratie wird ein schub
automatisch bringen das werden wir in
die beratungen einbringen
und beim ausbau der windenergie die
beschleunigt werden muss auch dieses
ziel teilen wir wo sich vorstellen
immerhin zum ausgleich von erneuerbaren
energien und atemschutz andere
vorschläge im planungsverfahren die
richtig sind möchten wir darauf dringen
dass der gedanke der regionalplanung
verstärkt wird die regionalplanung ist
die möglichkeit ziele verbindlich
festzulegen und dann tatsächlich auch im
planungsverfahren eben in dialog im
ausgleich zu erreichen aber gleichzeitig
akzeptanz zu schaffen mit anderen
anliegen das ist uns ein besonders
wichtiges anliegen und das kann nur
erreicht werden mit einem engen mit
einer engen abstimmung mit den
bundesländern wir brauchen ein breites
gesellschaftliches bündnis das beginnt
aber damit dass ihre reise durch die
bundesländer ist echte verhandlungen
folgen in denen man sich auf ziele auf
instrumente auf ein gemeinsames vorgehen
verständigt da haben wir die erwartung
dass das jetzt der nächste schritt ist
das haben wir bisher nicht wahrgenommen
dass aber notwendig um die fortschritte
notwendig sind mit breiter akzeptanz
voranzubringen herzlichen dank
andreas der
klimaschutz und energiepolitischen
sprecher der unionsfraktionen konnten
sie auch ein viertel von neun schon bei
uns im interview sehen und wie ist die
fügung und der zufall will die nächste
rednerin auch schon heute morgen bei uns
im interview gewesen nina scheer aus der
spd fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
bereits vor dem russischen angriffskrieg
und den sich angeschlossenen maßnahmen
zur beendigung der import abhängigkeiten
von energie aus russland war der
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien die zwingende und
schlüssige konsequenz zur begrenzung des
menschgemachten klimawandels nun muss
aber eben jetzt erst recht vor dem
hintergrund des angriffskrieges gelten
diese politik beschleunigt zu verfolgen
auch um dich erpressbar zu werden die
bundesminister wird habe gerade schon
erläuterte kündigte russland gestern
un-sanktionen gegen teile des
gaskonzerns gazprom germania an der seit
anfang april unter der
treuhandverwaltung der bundesnetzagentur
steht und es ist noch offen welchen
einfluss dies auf die weiteren importe
haben wird auch wenn aktuell die
gasversorgung gesichert ist genau zu
beobachten ist aber an dieser stelle
auch wenn von seiten der ukraine zur
zeit ein durchleitung stop von gas aus
russland verfolgen wird es muss auch
hier ausgeschlossen werden können dass
diese maßnahmen nicht ein gegen
deutschland gerichtetes druckmittel sind
auch dies wäre inakzeptabel
wirtschaft und gesellschaft sind auch
ein verlässlicher auf eine verlässliche
energieversorgung angewiesen und zwar
weltweit
bereits die endlichkeit fossiler
ressourcen bei gleichzeitig steigender
weltbevölkerung und noch dringlicher die
klimafolgen wirkungen aus verbrennung
fossiler energieressourcen erfordern
verstärktes handeln wir brauchen den
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien
wir brauchen wir brauchen die
beseitigung von mengenbegrenzungen die
sich über die letzten jahre angehäuft
haben und wir brauchen die beseitigung
von vielen versteckten planungsgemäß
hemmnissen
in diesem handeln steckt die chance auf
energiesicherheit es steckt die chance
auf überwindung von konflikten und
kriegen um fossile ressourcen die wir
schon hatten etwa in den irak kriegen
und auch auf vermeidung von massiven
gesundheitsschäden die durch die
verbrennung fossiler ressourcen sowie
weitere klima und umwelt folgewirkungen
entstehen und in diesem land steckt auch
die vermeidung von biodiversitäts
verlusten durch klimawandel der beste
garant arten zu erhalten ist den
klimawandel zu stoppen
wenn wir also nur mit den oster paket
das wir nun parlamentarisch behandeln
für 20 30
20 30 von 750 terawattstunden bedarf an
strom ausgehen ist dass deutlich mehr
als die heute benötigten 500 60
terawattstunden und wenn wir dann davon
80 prozent also von diesen 750
terawattstunden 80 prozent strom aus
erneuerbaren energien haben wollen so
steht es in unserem koalitionsvertrag
dann ist das so viel wie wir heute an
energie 100 prozent dann hätten das ist
uns das was wir vorhaben in acht jahren
wollen wir 80 prozent erreichen das ist
die menge die auf heute bezogen eine 100
prozent versorgung durch erneuerbare
energien bedeutet das ist ein großer
kraftakt das ist aber auch notwendig um
genau diese
schwierigkeiten die ich gerade erläutert
happ zu überwinden und es muss uns klar
sein die erneuerbaren energien sind die
günstigsten formen energie zu gewinnen
die kostengünstigsten formen und je
schneller wir es schaffen auf diese
umzusteigen desto schneller machen wir
uns unabhängig von preissteigerungen und
desto schneller machen wir uns
unabhängig von erpressbarkeit die
aktuell wegen importe fähigkeit bestehen
um nochmal kurz anzuschließen die sonne
schickt uns keine
20-jährige oder 15-jährigen
vertragsbindung
mit oder mit französische besprochen
gesprochen sie schickt die sonne schickt
uns keine rechnung solange die nutzung
fossiler energien noch nicht gänzlich
überwunden wurde und aktuell an einem
umstieg auf alternative bezugsquellen
auch für fossile energien gearbeitet
wird darf es zu keiner schleichenden
faktischen bevorzugung von fossilen
energieträgern gegenüber erneuerbaren
energien führen wenn wir heute etwa das
lg gesetz auch mit einbringen auf das
meine kollegen timon gremmels und auch
denkwerk noch eingehen werden wird es
auch darauf kommen ankommen dass hier
verbriefte öffentliche interesse das
überragende öffentliche interesse was
angesichts der notlage dort verbrieft
ist für den bau von lng an landes
möglichkeiten
auch in übertragung auf erneuerbare
energien zu verbriefen es darf nicht
rein
es darf nicht sein dass wir zu einer
schleichenden ziel verschiebung kommt
durch diese prioritätensetzung die
angesichts des krieges auch uns
hereinprasselt und wir dann am ende von
solchen gesetzgebungsverfahren auf
einmal erkennen müssen wir haben eine
bevorzugung von fossilen energieträgern
gegenüber erneuerbaren nein es muss
umgekehrt seien die erneuerbaren
energien müssen immer das bevorzugte
sein sonst nehmen wir uns in der
energiewende statt sie zu befördern und
natürlicher jungs darauf auch noch mehr
einzugehen natürlich darf es auch keine
deckelung keine neuen deckelungen im
kontext der europäischen rahmen setzen
die wir haben geben sondern die
erneuerbaren energien sind ohne decke
voran zu bringen das ist das primat der
erneuerbaren energie es stellte sich
zudem die aufgabe
engpässe zu überwinden wir haben
massiven lieferketten schwierigkeiten
die betreffen natürlich auch die
energiewende auch hier müssen wir
schnellstens handeln es darf nicht sein
dass diese auswirkungen sich auch in der
energiewende niederschlagen wir haben
enorme weichenstellungen vor mit dem
oster paket die planungs förmliche die
genehmigungs hemmnisse zu überwinden
eine reihe von maßnahmen sind dort
enthalten weitere folgen noch durch
weitere vorlagen wie auch das sind
vielleicht ein beschleunigungsgesetz was
uns in den nächsten wochen noch
erreichen wird ich freue mich auf die
konstruktive zusammenarbeit in der
ampelkoalition die wirklich vieles vor
ort und vieles auch schon angeschoben
hat und jeder ist eingeladen dies
konstruktiv zu begleiten vielen dank
nina scheer ist in der spd
fraktionssprecherin für klimaschutz und
energie und hertie den standpunkt ihrer
fraktion noch einmal dargelegt in einer
debatte in dem es um in denen es über
drei gesetzentwürfe der bundesregierung
geht zum ausbau erneuerbarer energien
und dazu jetzt aus der afg fraktion
steffen kothe der energiepolitische
sprecher
damen und herren minister habeck wenn
die russen jetzt gegen sanktionen machen
ist das doch nur eine reaktion auf
dem umstand dass sie doch angefangen
haben energie als waffe einzusetzen sie
haben doch vom öl embargo gesprochen was
sie umsetzen wollen und viele viele
andere dinge auch also wenn jetzt der
bumerang zurückkommen dann muss man sich
eigentlich nicht wundern und der ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien das ist eben
kein abschied von fossilen das ist
einfach nur ein abschied von der
vernunft meine damen und herren weil wir
ohne fossile gar nicht auskommen
und natürlich haben sie richtigerweise
angesprochen dass wir in einer welt
jetzt immer mehr probleme haben eben mit
der versorgung mit lebensmitteln
aber eben auch sehen wir dass wir
energie armut haben und wir tragen auch
dazu bei indem wir unsere
energieversorgung schreddern und hier
wolkenkuckucksheim machen wollen mit
diesen sogenannten erneuerbaren
funktioniert nicht wir sehen dass die
energieversorgung nachlässt und abgebaut
wird und dann ist natürlich ganz klar
dass wir dann keine energie mehr
woanders auch zur verfügung haben und
die so genannte bürger energie die ich
immer höre wo sich also bürger jetzt
selber um die stromerzeugung kümmern
sollen ja das ist doch irgendwie ein
zeichen dass wir wieder viel zu
mittelalterlichen zuständen zurückkommen
nein wir haben eine arbeitsteilung in
unserer volkswirtschaft in dieser
arbeitsteilung das unternehmen dafür
zuständig dass sie den strom erzeugen
und frau dr
die erneuerbaren energien sind nicht
billiger ist fossilen sondern teurer
bestes beispiel streichen doch das
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz ist dann
steigen wir damit auf die subvention und
sie werden sehen dass die erneuerbaren
energien nicht mehr ausgebaut werden
können weil sie völlig uniko mission
sind also das ist mein bestes beispiel
und die fossilen werden nicht bevorzugt
nein im gegenteil sie werden behindert
ihn genau durch das erneuerbare energien
gesetz weil sie nämlich immer dann
zurücktreten müssen wenn die
erneuerbaren
instabilen ins netz eingespeist werden
müssen also das völliger coco logos zu
sagen dass fossile hier bevorzugt werden
und man kann im übertragenen sinne auch
sagen dass der ausbau der windenergie
ein ausbau von parasitärer energie ist
denn diese wetter in einer abhängigen
wind industrieanlagen die brauchen
nämlich diese fossile stromerzeugung
nicht immer dann wenn sie wenn sie
aussetzen und keinen strom erzeugen und
dann springen nämlich die fossilen ein
so ist das nämlich und nicht anders und
das erneuerbare energien gesetz erhält
die erneuerbaren instabilen energien
einfach nur künstlich am leben meine
damen und herren
und wenn wir uns die wild
industrieanlagen anschauen dann sehen
wir dass das also umweltverschmutzer
sind beton stahl öl und kahlschlag in
unserer landschaft lärm im feld und flur
und nunmehr lesen wir das also diese
industrieanlagen sogar leider in
schutzgebieten naturschutzgebiete
aufgestellt werden dürfen und das ist
ein unding das ist völliger unding und
es gab mal eine umweltschutz partei und
sie ist aber leider längst beerdigt gab
auch mal eine friedenspartei ist auch
beerdigt gegenteil ist leider der fall
und wenn wir uns also diese
windindustrie anlagen noch mal genauer
anschauen dann gibt es ja die neuesten
studien auch die sagen sie führen zu
mehr wärme und trockenheit in mikroklima
bereich neueste studien sagen das und
das ist ja genau das gegenteil von dem
was sie vorgeben eigentlich mit diesen
windindustrie anlagen auswirken zu
wollen und insofern ist das wieder ein
irrer soziale aspekt in dieser gesamten
irrationalen energiepolitik in dieser
gesamten welt dümmsten energiepolitik
meine damen und herren
ja und woran erkennen wir diktaturen wie
erkennen sie an der einschränkung der
rechte und woran erkennen wir die
anfänge einer links-grünen gelben
ökodiktatur eben genau an der
einschränkung der
einspruchsmöglichkeiten für die bürger
und wenn ich höre dass schon wieder
diskutiert wird dass man die
abstandsregeln zu wohnhäusern jetzt
schleifen will das also jeder in seinen
vorgarten so einer windindustrie an da
hingestellt bekommen kann und dann auch
noch der prozess weg eingeschränkt ist
meine damen und herren wer dann hat das
nichts mehr mit einem rechtsstaat zu tun
so wie wir ihn verstehen meine damen und
herren und so wie wir ihn von der afg
auch verteidigen
und windindustrie anlagen jetzt noch als
nationales als gegenstand der nationalen
sicherheit zu deklarieren also das war
völliger wohnen im gegenteil diese
windindustrie anlagen sind nationales
sicherheitsrisiko für mensch wird hier
für umwelt und für die versorgung
machen hier lieber in kernenergie da
kommen wir besser
dankeschön
stephen corry der energiepolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion mit der
perspektive auf dieses thema das hier
heute vormittag im bundestag verhandelt
und diskutiert wird es folgte michael
grusa muss der fdp fraktion aber er ist
energiepolitischer sprecher
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrter herr kurth sie sprechen von den
anfängen einer diktatur ich stelle mal
fest in diesem land besteht
meinungsfreiheit die tatsache dass sie
von diesem pulk hier jeden schuss ab
sondern dürfen denen sie sich zu
überlegen das beste indiz dafür dass sie
diesen mann meinungsfreiheit ich
kann ja verstehen
ich kann ja verstehen dass sie sich
gerne weiterhin auf russland verlassen
möchten ein blick in die zahlungsströme
die es so in ihre richtung gibt legt
nahe sie können diesen abstand auch
finanziell nicht gut verkraften aber wir
alle wissen dass die großen koalitionen
die letzten beiden großen koalitionen
sich genau wie sie auf russland
verlassen haben und ich stelle fest
jetzt sind wir verlassen weil wir uns zu
lange auf russland verlassen haben und
deswegen und deswegen unternehmen wir
jetzt mit höchstgeschwindigkeit alle
maßnahmen die erforderlich sind um uns
unabhängig zu machen von russland
deswegen besprechen wir hier heute das
lng infrastruktur beschleunigungsgesetz
deswegen gehen wir mit fullspeed voran
wenn es darum geht jetzt alternativen zu
schaffen zu dem was sie gerne noch
weiter etablieren wird wir gehen diesen
weg mit uns zum glück folgt uns ein
großer teil der bevölkerung in
deutschland meine lieben kollegen
wir machen ja aktuell den größten ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien denen es in
den letzten 25 jahren wahrscheinlich
jemals gegeben hat und mit diesen großen
ausbaus auch eine große verantwortung
verbunden insbesondere auch für uns hier
im hause im verfahren denn es ist ja
nicht üblich dass wir in diesem
verfahren ein gesetzentwurf durch das
kabinett durchgeht und ist an der einen
oder anderen stelle abgestimmter weise
noch diskussionsbedarf gibt ich bin dem
minister deswegen sehr dankbar dass er
hier in dem minister sehr dankbar dass
er hier an dieser stelle auch die
entsprechenden punkte entsprechend
eingeordnet hat denn die verantwortung
für den erfolg dieses gesetzes liegt
jetzt bei diesem haus und auch die
verantwortung für eine einigung über
wichtige ziele die wir mit diesem gesetz
erreichen wollen liegt bei diesem haus
und gerade in richtung derjenigen die
jetzt immer dazwischen schreien sage ich
auch sie liegt nicht nur bei denjenigen
die hier die regierung tragen sondern
einfluss auf dieses verfahren hat jeder
einzelne und jede einzelne abgeordnete
und wir haben mit den beiden
gesetzgebungsverfahren die wir jetzt
bereits abgeschlossen haben im bereich
der gasspeicher und im bereich der
energiesicherheit gezeigt dass wir
konstruktive hinweise aus der opposition
sehr wohl bereit sind nicht nur zur
kenntnis zu nehmen sondern auch in
unsere gesetze einzuarbeiten
herr kollege das ist nicht großzügig
sondern das ist klug nein ich tun nicht
nur so sondern wir bauen gute
entscheidungen gute ideen auch aus der
opposition sind wir uns nicht zu fein
dafür
das aufzunehmen wissen sie was das
problem mit ihnen ist das problem ist
aus dieser richtung ist noch kein
einziger konstruktiver vorschlag
gekommen für unsere gesetze dass das
ganze problem
wir wollen mit wir wollen mit dem
erneuerbaren energien gesetz dafür
sorgen dass wir klimaneutrale
energieversorgung
erreichen wir möchten dass in
deutschland ein luxusgut zum standard
wird das ist das was wir hier machen wir
sorgen dafür dass die erneuerbaren
energien für jeden bezahlbar werden wir
sorgen auch dafür dass an den stall
stellen wo wir gesehen haben es gibt
eine riesen kostendegression wir haben
die erneuerbaren nämlich in allen
bereichen hingelegt sehen das nicht zur
kenntnis genommen aber es hat trotzdem
der fall dass in den bereichen wo die
kostendegression so groß ist dass es
möglich ist auch ein einstieg in den
ausstieg der dauersubventionierung
erfolgt nicht das ziel entschuldigung
gestatten wir eine zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion wir selbstverständlich
von dem nennen
natürlich so die spielfrage zugelassen
von der führen sie zu sein die
präsidentin mit mir spricht oder ich mir
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zugelassen haben sie haben gesagt sie
würden konstruktive vorschläge von uns
würdigen wir haben beim ensi gestern
erlebt dass sie unseren vorschlag
abgelehnt haben obwohl wir mehrfach
vorher auf das problem hingewiesen haben
dass für die treuhänder im bereich von
[Musik]
von den fossilen energien also natürlich
insbesondere gas von deutschland und
france neff
das ist der ungelöster rechtsfragen gibt
wir haben dazu gestern ein
änderungsantrag gemacht haben sie
abgelehnt das heißt auch ihr
zwischenrufe würden gar keine vorschläge
machen ist sowohl nicht zutreffend
warum haben sie denn eigentlich
abgelehnt ja kann ich ihnen gerne baden
zunächst mal alles was was ich hier eben
vom rednerpult gesagt habe hat sich
ausdrücklich in dieser sache nicht an
ihre fraktion gerichtet sondern ich
hatte ja vielmehr darauf hingewiesen
dass es aus ihrer fraktion auch
konstruktive hinweise zum endsieg bisher
die debatte zum endsieg heute abend
deswegen werde ich die nicht in gänze
vorziehen aber sie haben sicherlich zur
kenntnis genommen dass wir kolleginnen
und kollegen aus ihrer fraktion intensiv
in den beratungsprozess zu diesem zu
diesem gesetz eingebunden haben auch
wesentlich intensiver als das übliche
oder notwendig ist und das hat er ja
gründe die gründe dafür waren dass wir
dieses gesetz wirklich großem tempo
durch dieses haus gebracht haben und wir
haben eben als regierungsfraktion auch
die verantwortung verstanden dass wir
auch oppositionsfraktionen auf dem weg
mitnehmen und auch konstruktive hinweise
aus diesem bereich aufnehmen sie finden
dass im bereich des m6 etwa wieder bei
der verordnung die sr geben muss für den
fall dass wir schwer wiegende
eigentumsrechtliche eingriffe vornehmen
in diesem fall muss eine verordnung hier
auch durch den deutschen bundestag sich
sogar genehmigungspflichtig durch den
deutschen bundestag in drei
sitzungswochen muss das passieren dass
ein vorschlag der wie ich ihnen sagen
kann explizit in der ersten lesung in
diesem hause von ihrem kollegen jungen
hier geäußert wurde ist etwas was wir
aufgegriffen haben weil es ein sehr
kluger ratschlag war und wie sie hören
wenn ich mir auch gar nicht zu fein
dafür diese klugen ratschläge von dieser
stelle ja auch auszuloben das heißt
allerdings nicht dass jeder vorschlag
der aus einer oppositionsfraktion kommt
am ende auch in jedem gesetz drin stehen
wird ich glaube dass allerdings werden
sie mir nachsehen können insofern ich
habe jetzt erläutert wann wir
konstruktive vorschläge und welche
konstruktiven vorschläge wie auch
aufgenommen haben an dieser stelle ist
es bei diesem einen geblieben und dann
alles weitere dazu vielleicht in der
debatte heute abend herr kollege
gut zurück zum
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz worüber wir
hier eigentlich gerade debattieren wir
haben schon im koalitionsvertrag
wichtige weichenstellungen vorgenommen
die zielstellung wir haben das
öffentliche interesse der erneuerbaren
energien deutlich hervorgehoben und wir
sind auch auf einem wichtigen weg uns
alle anderen bereiche die hier in der
öffentlichkeit und in der
fachöffentlichkeit kritisch diskutiert
werden noch einmal anzuschauen die
kleine wasserkraft ist angesprochen
worden und ich kann für unsere fraktion
sagen dass es uns auch sehr wichtig ist
darauf zu schauen dass das geld was wir
hier für den erneuerbaren ausbau
einsetzen auch wirklich die volle
wirkung entfalte dass wir also sehr
darauf gucken werden welchen grenznutzen
der eingesetzte euro betrifft das wir
ihnen gerade da einsetzen wo er den
maximalen nutzen erzielt damit wir mit
dem ausbau der erneuerbaren rest möglich
und schnellst möglich vorankommen
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksamkeit
michael kruse aus der fdp-fraktion hat
zwischendrin noch eine zwischenfrage von
thomas heilmann beantwortet und jetzt
gibt es in der debatte weiter klaus
ernst ist der nächste redner aus der
fraktion die linke in der letzten
legislaturperiode also in der vorherigen
war er wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher
der
beschleunigte ausbau erneuerbarer
energien
ist nicht nur ein gebot der stunde das
war eigentlich schon vorher das soll
unterstützen wir natürlich folge
richtungen die es jetzt geht
wie freute auch dass die union jetzt
auch voll mit macht der junge es war
nicht immer so im letzten jahr habe ich
den eindruck habe sie stand ein bisschen
auf der bremse das hat auch ihr
koalitionspartner damals auch oft
bemängelt wenn wir jetzt
wenn wir jetzt eine neue dynamik haben
dann ist es gut und richtig
das ziel ist ambitioniert
windenergie
8,5 jahre verdoppeln
photovoltaik-anlagen dreieinhalb mal so
viel windenergie auf see über filme
nicht richtig verstanden habe
ich glaube wir müssen auch darüber reden
was alles passiert das wird es
vielleicht nicht erreichen könnten und
dann über die schranken reden die
versuchen die die wir versuchen müssen
zu lösen dass wir dieses ziel auch
erreichen denn bis jetzt stets nur auf
dem papier bis jetzt ist noch nicht
passiert das heißt bis jetzt haben wir
noch genau dieselben abhängigkeiten wie
vorher die wir ändern wollen und ich
sage ihnen eins aus dem entgegen steht
was sie vorhaben das ist die frage
wie entwickeln sich eigentlich die
preise weil alles was sie vorschlagen
erfordert ein höchstmaß an investitionen
auch der privaten und wenn ich dann den
privaten zu hören wir hatten jetzt
montag eine anhörung bei uns im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
dann sagt zum beispiel die glasindustrie
dass allein durch die preissteigerungen
bei energie die wir zurzeit haben ein
sinnvoller betrieb von von glashütten in
der bundesrepublik kaum noch wirklich
ist wir hatten da einen er hatte
überlegt sogar seine künftigen
investitionen in den usa zu machen nicht
mehr bei uns wir haben gleichzeitig hohe
preissteigerungen bei denen die wir
brauchen für investitionen dass sie das
was man mit neuen energien erreichen und
auch umsetzen und da sage ich dann ist
man schon darüber nachdenken ob das
was wir momentan da machen auch
hinsichtlich des sanktionen haben
wirklich zielführend ist wenn wir sagen
wenn wir sagen wir sind ja das sagen bis
jetzt liefern die russen an uns
jedenfalls zuverlässig bis jetzt aber
wenn wir natürlich denken dauernd sagen
wir nämlich und mit euch euren kram
nicht mehr ab dann ist natürlich auch
irgendwann zu überlegen was machen
eigentlich die anderen also beim schach
aber gelernt wenn ich anzug macht muss
ich überlegen bevor ich denn machen was
macht der andere weg was kommt ja ich
konnte reagieren und selbstverständlich
hätten wir ein riesenproblem das wird
jetzt wenn das eintritt was sie am
anfang ihrer gegen die dargestellt haben
werden tatsächlich aufgrund dessen wie
die russen jetzt reagieren wie eine
energieversorgung stopp mit gas hätten
also wäre es doch jetzt auch ihre
aufgabe als bundesregierung zu gucken
wie könne man dies verhindern
nicht nur wie kümmern das weit mit
weiter unsererseits installationen ton
sondern körperlich verhindern weil ich
habe den eindruck wenn man so
weitermachen gefährden wir mit unserer
politik auf dieser seite die
energiepolitik die wir wollen auf der
anderen seite und dann haben mit
zitronen gehandelt aber nichts erreicht
haben
[Applaus]
richtig da ist es nicht so wichtig da
ist es nur richtig dreht sich die klagen
immer die raffinerien spät ich war dort
sie waren auch bleiben verfeuert wird so
werde ich mit den leuten gesprochen habe
ich ja es war halt so wie konnten sie
verhindern
wenn ich mit den leuten sprechen sagen
sie ja wir haben ein riesenproblem weil
die logistik für alternativen dass wir
dieses ist also die ölversorgung weiter
befreit überhaupt noch nicht gegeben ist
wenn ich danach rechne die vorschläge
die es gibt da komme ich zu dem ergebnis
dass es keineswegs so ist dass jeder der
in irgendeiner weise gesichert ist also
ich bitte sie einfach darüber
nachzudenken dass wenn man die ziele die
sich hier vortragen und die sind ja gut
und richtig die unterstützen wir auch
gerne aber dann müssen doch alles tun
dass es auch klappt umklappen tut ist
nicht eben durch die maßnahme die man
sonst eher greifen zu einem preis
entwicklung
beitragen die nicht nur die bürger in
einer unerträglichen weise belastet
sondern auch die unternehmen weil sie
investitionen diese für neue energie
brauchen nicht habe und deshalb
überlegen sie bitte ob das alles richtig
ist was ich so was sie tun sonst sind
ihre ambitionierten ziele die wir
nachdrücklich unterstützen eigentlich
für die johnny herzlichen dank
klaus ernst aus der linksfraktion
vorsitzender im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie ist folgt julia
verlinken aus der fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen stellvertretende
vorsitzende dort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren man kurz auf das
angesprochene energiegesetz einzugehen
dass wir jetzt im parlament beraten
werden dabei ist natürlich wichtig dass
wir uns mit den europäischen partnern
abstimmen auch deren geplanten
kapazitäten im blick haben dazu gehört
natürlich dass wir sorgfältig bei den
aufzubauen in kapazitäten um eine gute
balance achten zwischen
selbstverständlich notwendiger notfall
absicherung für den fall der fälle in
den nächsten jahren um
selbstverständlich auch eine
wirtschaftlichkeit dieser kapazitäten
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu dass
es bei der laufzeit für fossile
flüssiggas nutzung auch auf die
klimaziele abgestimmt wird und last not
least dass es eine in dieser
krisensituation angemessene beteiligung
für öffentliche belange gibt
denn klar ist doch klar ist doch dass
der erdgasverbrauch bei uns in europa in
den nächsten jahren deutlich sinken wird
und zugleich muss die dringend
notwendige infrastruktur auch für
wasserstoff aufgebaut werden ich denke
wir werden sehr verantwortungsvoll und
zügig diesen gesetzentwurf beraten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen eine
fundamentale transformation unserer
gesellschaft steht an wir handeln gegen
die stetig steigende temperaturen und um
die eskalierende klimakrise abzubremsen
vorgestern teilte die
weltwetterorganisation mit dass ein
überschreiten der 1 5 grad grenze schon
bis 20 26 möglich sein in deutschland
haben wir im jahresdurchschnitt die 2
grad erhitzen schon fast erreicht und
hier in berlin und brandenburg geht es
jetzt in das fünfte jahr der dürre
das gesetzespaket ist ein wichtiger
schritt gegen das fieber des planeten
und zugleich eine krisenreaktion gegen
teurere energiepreise gegen fossile
inflation und gegen fossil
abhängigkeiten
und was wir heute im parlament
einbringen das hätte schon vor jahren
passieren müssen wir stellen als erstes
den zielkorridor neu auf mit ausbau
fahren bei windenergie und solar energie
die uns auf den weg zu einem
dekarbonisierung stromsektor bringt es
liegen noch einige wochen debatten vor
uns bis wir uns hier zum beschluss
dieser gesetzesnovellen wiedersehen aber
schon jetzt ist sicher wir werden uns
für die besten bedingungen für den
ausbau der erneuerbaren einsetzen die
wir in den letzten 20 jahren hatte
damit ist das startsignal das
startsignal für den turbo ausbau jetzt
da im eeg stellen wir nun auch fest was
in diesen tagen so offensichtlich ist
wie nie die erneuerbaren energien sind
im öffentlichen interesse das stand
übrigens bereits auch mal in einem
entwurf der eeg-novelle in der letzten
legislatur aber das nicht von der union
haben das dann schnell lieber wieder
gestrichen ist also ein schönes beispiel
für ihre energiepolitische
kurzsichtigkeit mein appell an sie alle
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen machen
sie im wahlkreis werbung für die
erneuerbaren energien setzen sie sich
ein setzen sie sich für die zweite
energien vor ort denn die dezentrale die
erneuerbare energieversorgung luft vor
ort gemacht das bild für das repowering
von alten windrädern genauso wie für die
flächen bereitstellung der neuen
solarparks wir schaffen hier im
parlament die grundlagen aber gebaut
wird vor ort also rauf mit der
photovoltaik auf die dächer auch auf
turnhallen und auf rathäuser liebe
kommunen stellen sie denn jetzt dringend
die benötigten flächen zur verfügung
ermöglichen sie die dringenden
notwendigen investitionen alle müssen
mithelfen damit wir schneller sind als
die klimakrise
mit dem neuen eeg wird es außerdem auch
endlich wieder raum für die bürger
energie geben dem energiewende hat eine
große unterstützung in der bevölkerung
und bürger energie ermöglicht dass alle
unbürokratisch selbst bei dieser trend
transformation mitmachen können zum
beispiel ohne ausschreibung loslegen
können plus die bundesregierung hat
bereits eckpunkte für ein separates
förderprogramm der bürgerenergie nach
dem vorbild von schleswig-holstein
vorgelegt ich bin dafür sehr dankbar
liebe freunde wir gehen und kollegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen packen
wir es an ich freue mich auf die
beratungen
die julia verwenden aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen hat das lg gesetz
angesprochen lng also liquefied natural
gas also verflüssigtes erdgas dass es
der vierte gesetzentwurf der hier heute
morgen und mit beraten wird nämlich die
infrastruktur für dieses verflüssigte
erdgas auszubauen in deutschland um gas
engpässe zu verhindern thomas heilmann
ist der nächste redner aus der
unionsfraktion meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen liebe oster paket gläubigen
wir unterstützen grundsätzlich die
intention ihres oster paketes den ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien in deutschland
drastisch zu beschleunigen und
ausdrücklich wir begrüßen und
unterstützen auch die von ihnen auch
heute morgen wieder genannte begründung
warum belassen
wir glauben allerdings nicht dass sie
ihre ziele und den versprochenen erfolg
mit diesen maßnahmen allein werden
erreichen können auch die folge
initiativen die sich ja schon
angekündigt haben und die natürlich
grundsätzlich auch den richtigen zieren
folgen werden diese ziele nicht
erreichen ruslan ist zwar das fest der
gläubigen aber wir sind noch keine
poster paket jünger und ich sage
ausdrücklich leider vielleicht kriegen
wir es ja noch irgendwie auch die ampel
redner gesagt haben warum werden sie
ihre ziele nicht erreichen erst muss sie
setzten zu wenig auf den markt und
stattdessen auf kleinteilige vorgaben
der staat kann nicht alles planen
sondern er sollte den rahmen und die
richtung vorgeben und innerhalb dessen
den markt die beste lösung finden lassen
ich will ihnen ein beispiel geben sie
geben ziemlich genau vor welches
geschäftsmodell sie unterstützen
entweder man speist ein vollständig oder
man verbraucht den strom selbst
kombination mit netz ziemlichen
speichern stellen sie schlechter sie
wollen keine biomasse andreas ion hat es
erwähnt selbst dann nicht wenn sie aus
stroh ästen oder anderen abfällen stand
wasserkraft leben sie praktisch auch ab
und nein frau verlinken auch die
bürgerenergie gesellschaften sind nicht
wirklich zufrieden und ich werde ihnen
gleich ein zitat von denen vorlesen ich
will doch zu sagen dass die informations
ausschreibungen zwar als instrument
jetzt fortsetzen aber in zu geringem
umfang diese gängelung sind grundfalsch
oder anders gesagt gerade an die adresse
der fdp freiheits energien brauchen
freiheit
zweiter grund problem das wir sehen ist
sie wollen nur den bau von windrädern
und photovoltaik dächern beschleunigen
was richtig ist aber genauso
entscheidend im ganzen system sind die
übertragungsnetze sind die speicher sind
die transistoren sind die neuen
digitalen steuerung die geothermie
elektrisieren alle neuen elemente für
unsere neue wird müssen beschleunigt
werden nicht nur bestimmte teile
denn die gesamte sich transformieren der
wirtschaft leidet unter langsamkeit
unnötigen vorschriften vielfach
dokumentationen widersprüchlichen
bescheiden und viel mehr wir müssen die
komplexität in unserem staat insgesamt
aber spezial gesetzliche änderungen sind
richtig und wichtig aber wenn das
grundproblem unserer blockierten
verwaltung nicht angegangen wird dann
wird deutschland zu langsam zu
bürokratisch und zu starb laden das
sagen wir eben jetzt nicht erst jetzt
sondern das sagen wir seit mehreren
jahren und sind ein bisschen enttäuscht
dass die neue ampel regierung auch bei
ihrer digitalstrategie die wirklich
entscheidenden schritte offensichtlich
nicht gehen richtet jetzt sehen sie
gleich sagen das ist dass kritik der
sich die ki diese kritik sei das nörgeln
der opposition bitte lesen sie einmal
die vielen stellungnahmen zu ihren oster
paket wie ein roter faden zieht sich
unsere kritik durch die analysen der
fachleute und betroffene ihr müsst auch
oft vorgetragen von institutionen die
sich seit jahren für klimaneutrale
wirtschaftsstarken habe der
bundesverband windenergie sagte sagt in
ihrer aktuellen version tragen die
vorschläge keinesfalls ausreichend zu
einer lösung der bestehenden blockaden
bald von einem bürokratie karussell über
alle föderalen ebenen stöhnt der
schwertransporter zuständige chef
anbieter kraftverkehr worden das bündnis
für bürger energien frau verlinken
widmet dem problem ein ganzes kapitel
zum oster paketen und an der schönen
überschrift bürokratische hürden bleiben
lösungen werden vertagt das gesetz dürfe
nicht so wörtlich als schönheits natur
in die geschichte eingehen gebraucht
würde die längst überfällige
administrative entschlackung des eeg ist
der förderverein solarenergie schreibt
in seiner analyse der versprochene
bürokratieabbau ist nur in wenigen
punkten umgesetzt wurden ja in anderen
feldern wurde der bürokratieaufwand
sogar noch erhöht das handelsblatt
resümiert warum habe ich öfter paket auf
der straße stecken bleibt und am schluss
noch am zurückhaltend formuliert der bdi
aber am ende doch sehr klar wichtig für
den rasten zubau von erneuerbaren
energien ist eine entschlackung starker
beschleunigung der genehmigungsprozesse
von einer zügigen neuregelung dieser
frage wird der erfolg der energiewende
entscheidend abhängen dem kann man nur
zustimmen meine damen und herren
bundesminister habe ich sie haben
natürlich recht wir stehen gemeinsam vor
einer enormen herausforderung und da
stehen wir natürlich auch an ihrer seite
wir müssen die fortschreitende
dramatische erderwärmung stoppen und
dafür ist der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien natürlich richtig
und so haben wir keine wahl das jetzt
gemeinsam als nation anzugehen und auch
im parlament haben wir natürlich keine
andere wahl als zu versuchen das
ostpaket dafür besser zu machen wie es
geht ganz nach der struktur regel kein
gesetz geht aus dem bundestag sowie im
haus wie es hineingekommen ist
ich freue mich dass sie dann dass ich
auch mit unseren
verbesserungsvorschlägen auseinander
setzen wir bieten den umfassende
mitwirkung an kritisch aber konstruktiv
wir stehen natürlich längst im austausch
mit den betroffenen unternehmen aber
auch sie meine damen und herren die sie
im saal hier sind oder an den digitalen
entgeht sie können sich an uns wenden an
die mitglieder unserer arbeitsgruppe
klima es gibt noch ein klima kreis der
fraktionen es gibt die klima union alles
angriffspunkte bei der sie auch ihre
verbesserungen einbringen können wir
christdemokraten wollen ein turbo für
die erneuerbaren ostern ist für christen
das feste hoffnung bleiben wir also auch
für das oster paket optimistisch vielen
dank
thomas altmann nochmal zum oster paket
mundart dann auch noch mal den begriff
ein bisschen präziser beleuchtet können
wir gerne auch noch mal ein wenig
ergänzen bis pfingsten jetzt noch
osterzeit insofern auch sprachlich hier
alles passend der nächste redner in
dieser debatte ist timon gremmels aus
der spd fraktion
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren diese vor bewertung sei
mir gestattet ich finde es immer
spannend wenn die union das redepult
tritt und dann erzählt die koalition die
ampel würde ihre ziele ihre
selbstgesteckten ziele nicht erreichen
also wer hat den 16 jahre hier regiert
das sollte man ihnen sozusagen noch mal
auf dem wir haben keine 16 wäre es wenn
die spd 16 jahre die kanzler gestellt
hat das kommt erst noch ja aber sie
haben mit frau merkel die kanzlerin
gestellt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren der heimat als die zeit mir nicht
mehr jetzt wissen sie wie es damals war
in der großen koalition peter altmaier
hat zu beginn der wahlperiode ein
sogenanntes 100 tagen gesetz eingebracht
und möglichst schnell kleinste reformen
am eeg vorzunehmen und es war ihre
fraktion die das blockiert hat wir waren
bereit sozusagen demokratie aus ihrem
hause kollege pfeiffer nüßlein oco haben
blockiert es war mir so peinlich dass er
einmal das gesetz umbenannt hat in
energie sammle gesetz weil es über 300
tage gedauert hat bis wir kleinste
änderungen vorgenommen haben und die
ampel macht es genau umgekehrt sie liegt
ein großer entwurf das oster paket heute
hier noch knapp 200 tagen auf den tisch
das ist der unterschied meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren zwischen der
großen koalition und der ampeln es ist
die größte reform im 21 jahr des
bestehens erneuerbaren energie gesetz
dass wir heute hier diskutieren und
heute einbringen wir legen damit den
nachhaltigen turbo zum ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien an meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und natürlich
haben die ampel parteien und fraktionen
einen ganz unterschiedlichen zugang zu
diesen themen die grünen kommen in
erster linie über die schiene
klimaschutz die fdp hat ihren weg mit
den zehen erneuerbaren energien über den
begriff der freiheit energie gewonnen
die spd steht den erneuerbaren energien
im sinne einer demokratisierung der
energieerzeugung an erster stelle da für
uns ist es wichtig die menschen
mitzunehmen ein mitmach projekt daraus
zu machen die bürger energien
voranzubringen weil das akzeptanz
steigert die kommunen mitzunehmen neue
einnahmequellen zu generieren die
stadtwerke mitzunehmen um auch
unabhängiger werden dort zu werden von
gas mieterinnen und mieter mitzunehmen
also auch menschen mit kleinerem
geldbeutel die vom preiswerten
sonnenstrom auf dem dach ihres
mietshauses profitieren das ist der
sozialdemokratische ansatz einer
energiepolitik meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und neben der
demokratisierung sozialdemokratie der
wirtschaftspolitische aspekt wichtig
weil energiewende ist klassische
wirtschaftspolitik wir schaffen hier
zukunftsfähige gute arbeitsplätze meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren die
voraussetzungen dafür schaffen wir weil
das handwerk gestärkt wird weil wir
immer mehr unternehmen auch aus der
solar branche wieder zurückkommt und
module auch in deutschland produzieren
wechselrichter in deutschland
produzieren und wir müssen dazu zu sehen
gemeinsam herberg dass wir auch die
windenergieindustrie hier in deutschland
behalten sie nicht abwandern lassen wir
brauchen gute standorte auch zur
fertigung von rotoren und von getrieben
der windkraftanlage das ist ganz wichtig
zu bienen und ähnliches ja und die ziele
die wir uns als koalition gesetzt haben
sind immens ich nehme nur das beispiel
der photovoltaik von wir haben hier eine
vervierfachung des zubaus 22 gigawatt
pro jahr wollen wir schaffen und da geht
es nicht dass wir freiflächen gegen
dachanlagen gegeneinander auszuspielen
wir brauchen beides um es zu gelingen
natürlich als erstes die dächer voll
machen aber wir müssen auch gucken dass
wir sinnvolle freiflächen nutzen um
diese ziele zu erreichen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ja und wenn
wir jetzt gesetzgeberisch die weichen
stellen dafür dass der zubau gelingt
müssen wir industriepolitische auch
gucken dass wir den fachkräftemangel
dass wir den lieferketten mangel
beseitigen weil ich auch aus meinem
wahlkreis unternehmen kennedy würden
gerade im bereich der erneuerbaren
energien deutlich mehr verkaufen wenn
dort der fachkräftemangel
beziehungsweise der lieferketten mangel
nicht gegeben wäre auch darum müssen wir
uns kümmern auch das muss moderne
industriepolitik meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und da wäre heute nicht
nur über siege reden sondern auch über
das lg beschleunigungsgesetz muss man
deutlich auch und ton hier werden
fossile energien beschleunigt das machen
wir nicht ganz freiwillig sondern weil
es eine notwendigkeit ist aber die
maßstäbe die wir hier anlegen beim
ausbau von energie ports die müssen
natürlich kann man nicht alles mit einem
vergleichen aber die müssen im grundsatz
nach auch für die erneuerbare energien
gelten wir können nicht zulassen dass
wir hier sonderwege für die fossilen
energieträger geht die einen lock in
effekt verursachen meine damen und
herren
und bei allem was wir tun ja wir haben
mit dem russischen angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine auch ein energieversorgungs
problem aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen
die klimakrise und die erderwärmung sind
nicht von der tagesordnung verschwunden
wir müssen beide krisen und beide
konflikte zeitgleich lösen da bieten die
erneuerbaren energien eine gute
voraussetzung ich sage ihnen
abschließend zu für die spd fraktion wir
haben hier von herr beck und der narr
werk von minister hahn berg und der
bundesregierung einen guten
gesetzentwurf bekommen es ist unsere
aufgabe als koalitionsfraktionen wir
laden die opposition also die
demokratische opposition hat sich einen
guten gesetzentwurf noch besser zu
machen in diesem sinne alles gute glück
auf
timon gremmels für die spd fraktion in
der debatte zu gesetzentwürfen der
bundesregierung zum schnelleren ausbau
erneuerbarer energien und auch zu einer
neuen infrastruktur für lng terminals
beispielsweise also den für flüssiggas
heftig ist wieder dran mit carsten hilse
heute um drei gesetzesentwürfe der
grünen kommunisten an das kann man die
ganze koalition nicht mehr nennen sie
alle wollen planwirtschaftlich die
stromerzeugung aus sogenannten
erneuerbaren in kürzester zeit drastisch
erhöhen als begründung wird die
alternativlosigkeit benannt und dass der
krieg in der ukraine die notwendigkeit
beschleunigter abkehr von fossilen
energieträgern einmal mehr aufgezeigt
hätte nicht nur dass sie das leid des
ukrainischen volkes durch den krieg hier
in unerträglicher weise
missbrauchen um eine völlig nutzlose nur
schaden verursachende sanktionspolitik
gegen russische grenze zu rechtfertigen
sie behaupten auch noch wider besseren
wissens und damit bewusst liegend weil
hundertfach widerlegt dass andere länder
unserem selbstmörderischen vorbild
folgenden
entspricht der dakota sagt wenn du
merkst dass du ein totes pferd reitest
steig ab statt nun aber von jedem toten
pferd energie wenn der austritt
abzusteigen versuchen die grünen müssen
herr gremlin ohne restalkohol geht's
besser
abzusteigen versuchen die grünen
kommunisten das mithilfe gewaltigen
entschuldigung herhalten so viele
studien gesprungen ich bitte dass sie
sich erstens entschuldigen und zweitens
auch diese begriffe weder nazi noch
kommunisten benutzen wir hier im hause
da würde ich sie auch darum bitten also
kommunist ist es verboten
dass das können sie gerne zu protokoll
nehmen weil wir gesagt haben wir
benutzen solche begriffe hier im hause
nicht man muss sich nicht daran halten
habe ich will trotzdem drauf hinweisen
ich bitte darum ich hab die redezeit
angehalten der hülse sie können jetzt
weiter vorfahren alles klar
ich entschuldige mich viel speicher in
gremmels ich gehe nicht davon aus dass
sie unter alkohol stehen
also
versuchen die grünen kommunisten des
mittels eines gewaltigen schuldenbergs
namens sondervermögens energie und
klimafonds wieder zum laufen zu bringen
da ist die rede von einer ausbeute von
10.000 megawatt jährlich für die
windenergie im land um bis 2030 die
fantasie menge von 130.000 megawatt
installierter leistung zu erhalten das
wären ab sofort 2000 vogel killer der 5
megawatt klasse das sind die richtig
großen pro jahr dafür bräuchten wir pro
jahr fünf millionen tonnen beton auf
mich und von stahl immerhin ein viertel
der deutschen jahresproduktion 430.000
tonnen aluminium eine millionen tonnen
kupfer und zehntausende tonnen von
rohstoffen die wir importieren müssen
und von gleicher hirnrissige qualität
ist sind die ausbauziele in der
photovoltaik bloß noch absurder das soll
es von rund 65.000 megawatt
installierter leistung auf
215.000 megawatt gehen pro pro tag dazu
60 megawatt müssen dazu hinzugebaut
werden grob gerechnet während das
600.000 quadratmeter fläche oder 80
fußballfelder jeden einzelnen tag die
stadt dresden plant sogar die
frauenkirche und die semperoper mit dem
chinesischen müll zu veranstalten und
wenn dann die sonne nicht scheint oder
der wind wehte vertrag trotzdem 0 sowie
130 tausend megawatt x 0 0 sind sind
auch
354.000 megawatt x 0 0 welch ein irrsinn
welcher eine anmaßung spricht aus diesen
gesetzentwürfen in anbetracht von 4.300
maroden autobahnbrücken wer in der
regierung denkt sich diese hirnrissigen
zahlen aber ist diese gesetze roben von
ideologen und realitätsverweigerung
getrieben die schamlose krönung ist dass
in diesem gesetz steht für die bürger
gebe es keine erfüllung aufwand aus
natürlich den höchsten energiekosten der
welt dem massenhaften verlust wirtschaft
mehr arbeitsplätze und der fehlende und
weiter teile des deutschen volkes wäre
all das nicht will wendet sich von den
altparteien ab bei den zukünftigen
wahlen und lehrt die einzige alternative
schönen tag
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
konrad stockmeier
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel koalition
trägt er den titel mehr fortschritt
wagen und ich möchte an dieser stelle
betonen dass putins angriff auf die
ukraine weder titel noch inhalt des
koalitionsvertrages obsolet gemacht hat
sondern vielmehr unterstrichen hat worum
es auch gehen muss nämlich auch darum
mehr tempo zu wagen das gilt
insbesondere auch für den netzausbau
der mit dem ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien unbedingt einhergehen muss und
sowohl bezüglich der übertragungsnetze
als auch der verteilnetze beides packen
wir unter anderem mit der novellierung
des energiewirtschaftsgesetzes an und
ich darf für die freien demokraten an
dieser stelle freudig feststellen dass
es da auch viele elemente gibt die in
richtung digitalisierung gehen und somit
das ganze sowohl für stromproduzenten
netzbetreiber als auch für endkunden an
vielen stellen vereinfachen wird die
zeiten in denen netzbetreiber lastwagen
zu irgendwelchen behörden fahren in
denen dann unterlagen sind die müssen
ein ende finden
ein weiteres kern gegen der freien
demokraten ist sehr wohl dass die kern
dass die energiewende auch so
kostengünstig und so marktgängig wie
möglich ins werk gesetzt werden muss und
ein entscheidender hebel um dies zu
realisieren
das möchte ich an dieser stelle betont
ist dass der netzausbau
bitte nicht nur deutsch sondern auch
europäisch gedacht und realisiert werden
muss in diesem sinne bin ich ihnen
minister habe ich sehr dankbar dafür
dass sie auch immer wieder betonen das
ist nicht um deutsche energieautarkie
gehen kann sondern wird wir das ganze
projekt auf europäisch denken müssen
denn mehr wären wir denn wenn wir das
projekt der freiheits energien nur bei
uns und nur für uns denken würden es
muss doch auch darum gehen nicht nur
unsere freiheit sondern auch die unserer
partner in der europäischen union und
darüber hinaus zu sichern
welches panorama tut sich da beim
netzausbau auch wenn man mit akteuren im
markt spricht das panorama des weit über
deutschland hinausgeht große offshore
wind kapazitäten beispielsweise in der
ostsee große photovoltaik kapazitäten in
süd europa und sagen wir es ruhig große
geschäftsmodelle und wenn wir an den
klimabeauftragten der us-regierung john
kerry denken das ist jemand der kein
problem damit hat sowas auch ein bid
business zu nennen und es stünde uns in
deutschland gut an wenn wir auch in
diese richtung denken und empfinden
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien und
der netzausbau wird
somit die europäischen union ihre
partner und unter unser aller freiheit
stärken und sichern und hat das zeug die
erneuerbaren energien wohlgemerkt auch
günstig zu machen und auch wirklich das
big business zu realisieren und da
möchte ich zum abschluss noch dazu sagen
aller freude die wir über den wahlsieg
von emanuele makro in frankreich
empfunden haben würde es uns jetzt auch
gut zu gesicht stehen seine
europapolitischen impulse nicht wieder
versanden zu lassen sondern sie
konstruktiv aufzunehmen warum bitteschön
auch nicht im bereich der energiepolitik
da gibt es viele chancen vielen dank
seit konrad stockmeier aus der
fdp-fraktion und ihm wird jetzt folgen
in dieser debatte über den ausbau
erneuerbarer energie in kathrin ohlig
aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren ich komme aus
nordrhein westfalen dem energie und
industrieland in nrw wissen wir dass für
wirtschaft und industrie eine
verlässliche und bezahlbare
energieversorgung unerlässlich ist denn
nur so können wir arbeitsplätze
langfristig sichern und den
wirtschaftsstandort attraktiv gestalten
aktuell steigen die energiepreise weil
die fossilen energien noch teurer
geworden sind teurer denn teuer waren
sich für menschen und umwelt schon immer
dabei sind die folgekosten der
klimakrise noch nicht einmal
berücksichtigt wir brauchen jetzt einen
schnelleren ausbau der erneuerbaren für
das klima aber auch für die wirtschaft
denn wenn der wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland in zukunft
wettbewerbsfähig soll sein soll der
minister hat es eben schon angesprochen
und wir arbeitsplätze sichern wollen
laufen wir erneuerbaren strom und grünen
wasserstoff für klimaneutrale
produktionsverfahren
die wirtschaft steht bereits in den
startlöchern und mit diesem
gesetzespaket schaffen wir
planungssicherheit für investitionen und
einen verlässlichen rahmen für den
schnelleren ausbau der erneuerbaren
für deren umsetzung muss dieser wind der
veränderung von bayern bis
schleswig-holstein von nrw bis sachsen
wen deutschland hat die kompetenz das
know how die ideen mit sonne und wind
den wirtschaftsstandort der zukunft zu
gestalten und damit gleichzeitig einen
wichtigen schritt zur begrenzung der
klimakrise zu leisten lassen sie uns mit
diesem gesetzespaket die chance dafür
nutzen und herr heilmann das ist sicher
erst der anfang
herzlichen dank
kathrin ohlig für die fraktion bündnis
90 die grünen hier wird jetzt folgen
andreas lenz aus der unionsfraktion um
als präziser zu sein aus der
csu-landesgruppe
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
bestehen bei 50 prozent erneuerbare
energien im strombereich wir sind also
die letzten jahre massiv voran gekommen
beim ausbau der erneuerbaren aber wir
brauchen auch weiterhin einen massiven
ausbau um die ambitionierten ziele zu
erreichen und es ist nicht alles
schlecht was in diesem paket steht dem
sogenannten oster paket aber eben vieles
auch nicht richtig gut und insofern
beschränke ich mich jetzt erst mal auf
die dinge die defizitäre sind die man
einfach auch besser machen könnte und um
es gleich zu beginn zu sagen wir
brauchen alle erneuerbaren wir müssen
die regionalen gegebenheiten optimal
nutzen und das wird in diesem oster
paket nicht gemacht ein ostergeschenk
ist es für viele eben nicht und so ist
es einfach nicht nachvollziehbar dass
die wasserkraft systematisch gegenüber
allen anderen erneuerbaren energien
benachteiligt wird
die wasserkraft soll als einzige
erneuerbare nicht im überragenden
öffentlichen interesse stehen julia
verbinden und da drängt sich doch die
frage auf da drängt sich doch die frage
des warum es auf man kann sich des
eindrucks einfach nicht erwehren dass
die geplanten lockerungen beim
artenschutz bei der windkraft durch
verschärfungen bei der wasserkraft quasi
eingetauscht wurden wasserkraft gehen
aber mit ökologischen gesichtspunkten
einher es wurde die letzten jahre viel
gemacht bei der durchlässigkeit auch
beim ausgleich zwischen ökonomie und
ökologie
wasserkraft ist grundlastfähig sie
stabilisiert das energiesystem insgesamt
das ist eine energieart die auch eine
insellösung darstellt gerade auch bei
problemen im energiesystem und ich
möchte an dieser stelle sagen die stehen
zwei wasserkraft und habe ich lade ich
sie gerne ein sich auch praxisbeispiele
entsprechend auch anzuschauen tendenz
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der fraktion bündnis 90
die grünen
lieber kollege lenz wir wissen ja dass
bayern sich sehr gerne an der
energiewende beteiligen würde was so
lang geht was wind angeht an dieser
entfesselung der erneuerbaren und
deswegen diskutiert die
csu-landtagsfraktion er schon lange
darüber wie können wir mehr flächen für
windenergie bereitstellen klar wir
wissen alle dass es eine einfache lösung
dafür gebe und daher würde ich ihnen
gern die gelegenheit geben heute hier im
plenum bei diesem top die abschaffung
der 10h windkraft abstandsregel zu
verkünden
ja liebe frau bahnschienen dann für die
frage das ergibt sich die möglichkeit
auch einiges dazu zu sagen es ist zum
einen so dass sehr viel heute in der
bild -zeitung quasi in der bild zeitung
verkündet werden dass dass sie die
abschaffung als sämtliche abstände ja
sowieso schon vorhaben das müssen sie
dann natürlich auch den bürgerinnen und
bürgern entsprechende erklären das ist
das erste und das zweite das zweite ist
dass wir in bayern die bayerische
landtagsfraktion der csu jetzt ein
maßnahmenpaket geschnürt hat auch
übrigens nach rücksprache von minister
habeck und ministerpräsident söder dass
wir natürlich mehr flächen brauchen in
bayern und ich glaube dass das ein
praktikabler weg ist aber lassen sie
mich eines am ende noch sagen der ausbau
der windkraft gibt nur mit den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und wir können
täglich über abstände diskutieren aber
es wird nicht funktionieren dass wir gar
keine abstände zu der wohnbebauung
letzten endes im gesetz auch fest
schreiben
aber sie haben sehr geschickt macht sie
haben ja eigentlich vom thema der
wasserkraft jetzt abgelenkt und das sagt
übrigens das sagen nicht wir sagen nicht
wir dass das worst case szenario dass
also der schlimmste fall für die kleine
wasserkraft
eingetreten ist dass die wasserkraft vor
dem ausschluss sagen nicht wir das sagt
der bundesverband erneuerbare energien
und wir werden das in dieser form nicht
akzeptieren meine damen und herren
ebenso ebenso wird das potenzial der
biomasse nicht hinreichend genutzt der
eeg kabinettsentwurf ist ein ausstieg
start für den bestand an bioenergie
anlagen und das ist ja gar nicht falsch
das ist ja gar nicht falsch das
biomethan stärker genutzt werden sollte
auch gerade für die spitzenlast
kraftwerke aber von den 900 9000 anlagen
in deutschland können dass eben die
allerwenigsten es ist doch so dass die
biomasse strom und wärme liefert beides
brauchen wir beides hilft auch
entsprechend die abhängigkeiten
insgesamt zu reduzieren biomasse biogas
könnte übrigens auch sofort mehr
produzieren könnte die abhängigkeit vom
russischen gas sofort entsprechend
minimieren aber sie wollen die biomasse
aus ideologischen gründen nicht da muss
auch schlicht nachgebessert werden und
da werden wir auch entsprechend unsere
forderungen gewicht verleihen ebenso
ebenso wird es riesige das riesige
potenzial der geothermie in keiner weise
adressieren wir brauchen auch weiter
innovationen wir brauchen technische
regelungen und auch lösungen um
entsprechend die energiewende zum erfolg
zu machen und airbags die sprechen ja
auch häufig vom energie einsparen und
energieeffizienz ist auf jeden fall
wichtig und richtig aber es findet sich
in dem aktuellen paket überhaupt keine
einzige maßnahme um die energieeffizienz
entsprechend auch zu stärken sie
unterscheiden die unterscheidung
letztlich doch im geplanten unser paket
in erneuerbare erster und zweiter klasse
wind wasserkraft schlecht tv gut
biomasse schlecht das ist
kontraproduktiv auch gerade in der
jetzigen krise wir wollen alle
erneuerbaren und wir brauchen auch alle
erneuerbaren um das klar zu sagen und
letztlich
letztlich steht bei ihrem paket auch
eine systemische betrachtung es findet
keinerlei integration statt es herrscht
nach wie vor das motto produce ein
vergelt also sozusagen produzieren und
sich dann nicht mehr um die mengen
kümmern wir brauchen mehr anstrengungen
bei einer frage des netzausbaus
auch bei der frage der verteilnetze bei
der markt integration und bei den
speichern und all diese punkte befinden
sich übrigens nicht im überragenden
öffentlichen interesse man muss also das
richtige auch richtig machen und dafür
stehen wir wir brauchen weitere planungs
beschleunigungen ist überhaupt keine
frage
und da könnten wir doch auch mal ein
beispiel gleich lösen das ist die frage
der ausgleichsflächen für jede tv eiche
brauchen zusätzlich ausgleichsflächen
und da bin ich das sind wir der meinung
dass er darauf verzichten können und wir
würden da mit einem einfachen schritt
sehr sehr vieles vereinfachen und auch
erleichtern da eben auch unser vorschlag
des entsprechend auch auszusetzen oder
abzuschaffen die betriebe aber auch die
privaten haushalte stöhnen weiter unter
den hohen energiepreisen
und deshalb braucht es auch weitere
entlastungen abschaffung der eeg-umlage
war ein richtiger schritt aber die
abschaffung der eeg-umlage kostet den
staat im moment überhaupt kein geld wir
müssen also die stromsteuer auf das
europäische minimum senken und
insbesondere die energieintensiven
unternehmen wie oft im internationalen
wettbewerb stehen weiter entlasten sonst
wird die energiekrise zur jobkrise und
genau das wollen wir nicht wir brauchen
also eine energiewende die richtig
gemacht ist und die vor allem mit und
für die menschen gemacht ist herzlichen
dank
andreas lernens aus der unionsfraktion
und weiter diskutiert über den ausbau
erneuerbarer energien und eine
sogenannte lng infrastruktur die
beschleunigte erstellt werden soll wir
sind aber schon beim drittletzten redner
angekommen und das ist bemerkt aus der
spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger ich bin
erschüttert wie tief das niveau hier von
rechts noch sinken kann
nichtsdestotrotz sei sehr zufrieden dass
diese stimme zumindest in ein
landesparlament jetzt verstummt ist und
schleswig holstein haben sie nicht ganz
gerecht
sagte er
herr eckert ich verstehe auch ihre rolle
als mahner hier aber die sind da schon
längst war weg die bundesregierung ist
schon nicht mehr beim mahnen und beim
teufel an die wand malen sondern schon
beim agieren jedenfalls was das
kurzfristige betrifft gasspeicher gesetz
allen sie gesetzt da sind wir schon
dabei aber wir müssen uns jetzt um die
langfristigen sachen kümmern deswegen
lassen sie mich ein bisschen die
tragweite unseres reform projektes auf
den punkt bringen was wir heute machen
dass wir heute auf den weg bringen ist
nichts geringeres als das größte
klimaschutz energiesicherheit
innovations- und zukunftspaket dieses
landes und dann darf das durch mal mit
diesem partner fragen nach der
dampfmaschine dem fließband den computer
der künstliche intelligenz schaffen wir
mit diesem gesetzespaket die
voraussetzungen für das gelingen der
fünften industriellen revolution denn
die unabhängigkeit die unabhängigkeit
von kohle öl und gas der ausbau von
wind- und sonnenenergie sind nicht mehr
aufzuhalten und das ist auch gut so das
ist gut für die unabhängigkeit von
russland das ist gut für die
energiesicherheit dass es gut für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland und das
ist gut für unsere kommunen vor allem
aber meine damen und herren ist das gut
für unsere kinder und enkelkinder und
dass sie
ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
deutschland ist das land der handwerker
und ingenieure
wir führen aber deutschland jetzt heraus
aus den fossilen energien und machen es
dazu doch zu dem weltweit führenden land
der innovationen der investition und
klimaneutraler industrie und lassen sie
mich das ganze anhand von drei punkten
mal etwas verdeutlichen erstens wir
wollen 20 45 ein klimaneutrales
industrieland sein dafür werden wir
alles tun wir werden dafür sorgen dass
künftige generationen noch eine
bewohnbare erde vorfinden und weiter
ihre träume verwirklichen können das
wird uns allen und so viel ist klar viel
abverlangt aber das ist allemal wert
klimaneutralität bis 20.45 das bedeutet
wir müssen richtig gas geben vom antrag
vom bis zum bau einer windkraftanlage
gene deutschland durchschnittlich 22
monate ins land nur für die planung da
muss noch gebaut werden 22 monate um das
zu verdeutlichen so lang tragen
elefanten die ihre babys aus sie können
sich ausrechnen wie lange das noch
dauert bis der strom fließt und das
können wir uns nicht mehr leisten
wir wollen runter auf die tragezeit von
rennpferden unter einem jahr muss drin
sein darum werden wir jetzt
beschleunigen und zwar nackt galopp
meine damen und herren
diese industrielle revolution ist eine
riesenherausforderung für unsere ganze
industriegesellschaft das wissen wir
aber es ist auch eine riesige chance
lassen sie mich den unternehmen in
diesem land vom kleinsten malerbetrieb
bis zum größten it-unternehmen folgende
botschaft mit auf den weg geben ohne sie
werden wir diese energiewende nicht
schaffe nutzen sie das
innovationspotenzial nachhaltiger
technologien entwickeln forschen sie
installieren sie helfen sie uns die
transformation made in germany zum
erfolg zu machen und gemeinsam schaffen
wir die wirtschaft von morgen und neue
gute arbeitsplätze hier in deutschland
und europa und eins das kann ich ihnen
versichern diese ampel koalition wird
sie mit aller kraft dabei unterstützen
drittens
wir stärken unsere kommunen und
beteiligen sie haben ausbau erneuerbarer
erneuerbare energie erzeugt wird werden
die städte und gemeinden finanziell
profitieren und davon haben dann alles
und jeder und jede von uns lebt in einer
kommune doch selbst die fdp liegt in
einer kommune braucht meint peter platz
gut und sichere gehwege haben gut
ausgestattete schulen und rathäuser und
auch dazu dafür werden wir sorgen
während die erneuerbaren einen beitrag
leisten ganz direkt vor ort und für die
menschen
jeder kolleginnen kollegen mit dem oster
paket machen wir unser land fit für eine
lebenswerte und sichere innovative
zukunft das wird kraft kosten aber wir
schaffen das wir schaffen das indem wir
aufhören darüber zu schnacken und
endlich anfangen es zu machen vielen
dank
denkwerk höhe die spd-fraktion und
zwischen spd-fraktion und grünen
fraktion setzt der abgeordnete stefan
seidler der als ein mandat gewonnen in
schleswig holstein ist mitglied im
südschleswigsche wählerverband
vertritt also die dänische minderheit in
deutschland und ist insofern
fraktionslos weil er der einzige
abgeordnete seiner partei im bundestag
ist aber gelegentlich da vergeben jetzt
zum beispiel länder uns noch einiges
voraus
dänemark gewinnt 56 prozent seiner
stromerzeugung aus wind weht am 36
135 und deutschland ist abgeschlagen mit
einem anteil von 23 prozent
norwegen ist seit 2015 ein enormer
sprung von unter 200 watt
windenergiekapazität pro kopf auf fast
900 watt in 20 21 gelungen das zeigt
wenn der politische wille vorhanden ist
können große aufgaben gelingen
zugleich müssen aber die ökologischen
belastungsgrenzen von nord und ostsee
berücksichtigt werden dennoch reden wir
heute auch vor allem über energie das
ist hier kaum erwähnt worden und lieber
herr minister habe über robert mit dem
pick mit diesem paket dies als besonders
umweltschonend zu verkaufen finde ich
schon ein bisschen zynisch
zu allem überfluss drohen nun
umweltverträglichkeitsprüfungen und
beteiligung von öffentlichkeit und
verbänden geschnitten zu werden im
schweinsgalopp die zementierung fossile
energien durchzusetzen ist ein großer
fehler es ist als würde die
bundesregierung in kutschen investieren
während draußen schon die eisen
beantwortet uns wieder auf die jahre an
fossilen zu ketten muss der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien im fokus stehen
damit wir die klimaziele noch erreichen
dass wir uns dabei nicht den wind aus
den segeln nehmen dankeschön
das war schnell zwei minuten hatte
stefan seidler vom südschleswigschen
wählerverband in dieser debatte zum
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien wir
sind inzwischen auch beim letzten redner
angekommen bei dieser beratung das ganze
wieder in den ausschüssen weiter
diskutiert werden und kommt dann über
kurz oder lang zurück ins plenum markus
humpert nochmal für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich muss das vielleicht auch mal sagen
windkraftanlagen sind keine verschmutzer
im gegensatz zur atomkraft die hier eine
fraktion immer wieder an heißt was
machen wir denn mit dem radioaktiven
müll das ist verschmutzung
wenn dieses gesetzespaket ein motto hot
dann ist es ein begriff den man in
letzter zeit häufig hört das öffentliche
interesse denn genau diesen dient es ist
im öffentlichen interesse dass wir eine
stabile energieversorgung haben denn wir
müssen uns darauf verlassen dass strom
fließt und wohnungen warm sind
es ist im öffentlichen interesse dass
wir eine nachhaltige energieversorgung
haben weil es nicht sein kann dass wir
strom und wärme auf kosten anderer
herstellen und verbrauchen
und es ist im öffentlichen interesse
dass wir eine bezahlbare
energieversorgung haben denn die
versorgung mit strom und wärme ist ein
absolutes grundbedürfnis doch leider
haben in der vergangenheit nicht alle
marktakteure das ziel einer stabil
nachhaltigen und bezahlbaren
energieversorgung
geteilt sie sprechen von den
billiganbietern die wie stromio ihre
kunden einfach im regen stehen haben
lassen
ihre praxis besteht darin kurzfristig
energie am markt einzukaufen ohne sich
langfristig gegen preisschwankungen
abzusichern
solange die marktpreise steigen niedrig
bleiben ist es auch für die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher günstig
und dadurch attraktiv
der haken ist wenn die marktpreise
steigen haben die unternehmen die
lieferungen einfach ein gestellt
vielleicht ist es ein tolles
geschäftsmodell aber sicher nicht im
öffentlichen interesse
denn am ende wird es für alle teurer
kollege hilfe gestatten sie eine
bemerkung oder zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion
strom und wärme es in ein grundbedürfnis
deswegen muss der grundversorger das
sind in der regel die örtlichen
stadtwerke
in diesen fällen eine ersatzversorgung
anbieten und zwar bis zu den konditionen
wie in der grundversorgung und das hat
vor allem kommunale versorger vor große
herausforderungen gestellt denn die
müssen ja kurzfristig energie zu hören
höhere höheren preisen einkaufen und
irgendjemand muss er bezahlen
etwa die bestandskunden und
bestandskunden oder die kommunen oder
der steuerzahler
das wäre nicht fair ist aber auch nicht
die menschen mit scheinbar günstigen
preisen zu locken die in wahrheit weder
stabil noch nachhaltig noch bezahlbar
sind und deswegen werden wir diese
praxis im energiewirtschaftsgesetz
ändern
zum einen stärken wir die grundversorger
die ersatzversorgung darf in zukunft das
kosten was für die energie tatsächlich
am markt bezahlt werden muss zum anderen
stärken wir aber die verbraucherinnen
und verbraucher discounter dürfen in
zukunft die belieferung nicht mehr
einfach einstellen
wenn sie aus dem markt ausscheiden
wollen müssen sie das mit einem vorlauf
von drei monaten ankündigen dass meine
damen und herren ist echter
verbraucherschutz das ist der weg zu
einer stabilen nachhaltige und
bezahlbare energieversorgung und damit
unser aller öffentliches interesse danke
markus sutter war das aus der
spd-fraktion und er war der letzte
redner in dieser ersten beratung von
drei gesetzentwürfen der bundesregierung
die sich mit dem ausbau erneuerbarer
energien beschäftigen und der
zusatzpunkt quasi am rande mit
diskutiert wurde ein gesetzentwurf
ebenfalls der bundesregierung da geht es
um die infrastruktur für
liquefied natural gas also das was als
verflüssigtes erdgas kämen das erheblich
leichter zu transportieren ist als das
gas weil es in einer flüssigen form nur
ungefähr 1 6 hundertstel des volumens
einnimmt als
gasförmigen form das ganze wird in den
ausschüssen weiterberaten werden ich
habe es eben schon gesagt hier geht es
weiter mit einem antrag der
unionsfraktion zu es geht um die
bekämpfung der preissteigerung und du
musst kurz zu machen heute am frühen
abend ist ja eben bundestag die end das
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
für bürgerinnen und bürger in der ersten
beratung und das geht aber der
unionsfraktion nicht weit genug deswegen
hat er eine ganze reihe von vorschlägen
zusammengefasst auch sehr
unterschiedlichen gebieten ist so ein
bisschen hat man vorübergehend den
eindruck eines sammelsuriums aber all
dieses bündel an maßnahmen hat die union
zusammengetragen um bürgerinnen und
bürger zu entlasten wir schauen mal eben
in den plenarsaal da ist noch eine
gewisse unruhe weil hier doch die
fachpolitiker jetzt ein wenig
durchwechseln und wir schauen wer der
erste redner sein wird michael meister
aus der unionsfraktion ist auf dem weg
zum pult und stellt den antrag der
unionsfraktion vor
heute steht die situation der menschen
in unserem land auf antrag der cdu csu
fraktion hier auf der tagesordnung
die preise schießen seit monaten in den
himmel
das war lange bevor der angriffskrieg
von russland auf die ukraine begonnen
hat aber die auswirkungen dieses krieges
beschleunigen die entwicklung
die menschen erleben dass tagtäglich an
der supermarktkasse wie die
lebensmittelpreise nach oben gehen die
menschen erleben dass an der tankstelle
bei den energiepreisen und da will ich
den hinweis geben dass viele
lieferverträge haben bei strom bei gas
mit festpreisen die irgendwann enden
werden das heißt wir sehen aktuell noch
nicht die volle wirkung der inflation
einen teil der wirkung wird erst in den
kommenden monaten auf die menschen
zukommen und das ist unabänderlich dass
es geschieht
und viele menschen in unserem land haben
vorgesorgt für die zukunft haben eine
altersversorgung aufgebaut außerhalb der
gesetzlichen rente und müssen jetzt
erleben dass über inflation das was sie
an vorsorge fürs alter aufgebaut haben
entwertet wird
und wenn wir die teuerungsraten sehen
aktuell von 7,4 prozent
dann ist es etwas was über mein herr
erfahrungshorizont und ich bin jetzt 28
jahre mitglied dieses parlaments
hinausgeht seit 40 jahren haben wir
keine solche entwicklung in deutschland
erlebt und deshalb müssen wir dringend
dagegen arbeitet meine damen und herren
nun ist es richtig dass zunächst mal die
verantwortung für die geldpolitik bei
der zentralbank liegt die unionsfraktion
respektiere die unabhängigkeit der
zentralbank
und die zentralbank hat ein mandat und
wir erwarten dass die zentralbank dieses
mandat in dieser außergewöhnlichen
situation entschlossen kraftvoll und
zeichner war nimmt meine damen und
herren es
gibt aber jenseits der geldpolitik der
zentralbank auch eine verantwortung der
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik und über
die finanz und wirtschaftspolitik in
diesem land müssen wir hier diskutieren
und es stellt die bundesregierung in der
verantwortung dort die notwendigen
entscheidungen zu treffen und bei der
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik gibt es an
diesem thema zwei dimensionen die eine
frage ist was können wir tun um die
ursachen der inflation zu bekämpfen wo
die zweite frage ist was können wir tun
per brandner sie haben auch gelegenheit
bringen sich sachkundigen dabei uns
keine wilden zwischenrufe zu machen
neben der dimension ursache gibt es die
frage auswirkungen und ich glaube wir
stehen die verantwortung dass wir uns um
beide themen kümmern wir müssen die
ursachen bekämpfen damit das nicht für
dauer wirkung wird und wir müssen die
auswirkungen auf die menschen bekämpfen
und jetzt hat nicht gestern sehr gefreut
herr bundesfinanzminister lindner da sie
ein strategiepapier zur angebots
orientierten politik vorgelegt haben ich
glaube dass solche gedanken einen
beitrag leisten können um gegen das
thema ursache etwas zu tun ich erwarte
allerdings dass es nicht ein papier des
bundesfinanzministers bleibt sondern
dass die bundesregierung sich dieses
papier umgehend zu eigen macht und dann
nicht nur ein papier auf dem tisch liegt
sondern dass die maßnahmen die zu
angebotsorientierten politik dort
genannt sind auch zeitnah umgesetzt
werden und da will ich mal ein beispiel
nennen wir hätten heute die chance
gehabt
handelsschranken abzubauen indem wir
über zeta enthalten sie haben es leider
an der tagesordnung genommen wir können
nicht entscheiden das während beitrag
zur angebots orientierten politik nicht
in einigen monaten sondern es könnte
heute geschehen hier in diesem haus wir
stehen vor der frage wo kommen wir aus
einer temporären inflation eine
dauerhafte entwicklung nämlich über die
frage kommen wir in eine
lohn-preis-spirale rein bisher haben wir
sie nicht und ich erwarte jetzt von der
bundesregierung dass sie alles in ihrer
kraft stehende tun um gegen eine solche
lohn-preis-spirale anzukämpfen denn es
kann nicht sein dass wir dauerhaft uns
in eine inflations situation hinein
begeben dort liegt in der verantwortung
handeln sie jetzt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
gibt eine reihe von themen ich will mal
heraus greifen das thema staatsschutz
die bundesregierung beabsichtigt im
laufe diesen jahres ermächtigungen
einzuholen für 300 milliarden euro neue
kredite darüber werden an anderer stelle
diskutieren aber ich erwarte dass wir
die schuldenbremse am ersten januar 2023
wieder einhalten das ist ein signal an
markt das ist ein signal an andere
länder in europa und es gibt der
zentralbank den spielraum den sie
dringend braucht um das vernünftige
geldpolitik zu machen und zum abschluss
weil mir die zeit frau präsidentin etwas
davon läuft geht noch viel zu sagen
wir haben auch in europa den stabilitäts
und wachstumspakt außer kraft gesetzt
auch das meer dringend notwendig dass am
ersten januar der wieder in kraft tritt
und ich erwarte dass man nicht sich in
der formulierung versteckt als
bundesregierung wir warten die prüfung
der kommission ab nein hier ist ein
klares signal an den markt und an unsere
anderen mitgliedstaaten im euroraum zu
erwarten vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit wir werden die diskussion
an anderer stelle dafür
michael meister für die unionsfraktion
und zu deren antrag bekämpfung der
inflation eine ganze reihe von
vorschlägen hat die union in diesem
antrag gemacht die gegenrede dazu von
verena hubert der stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wo soll ich
anfangen
zu schreiben und sprechen von angst ihr
antrag der art mit angst wir leben in
einer zeit von angst angst vor krieg
angst vor inflation angst vor
wohlstandsverlust und sie sagen was
können wir denn tun haben sie nicht
mitbekommen was wir tun nämlich eine
ganze menge also ich meine
entschuldigung ich sechs war noch alles
ausgebucht und mitgebracht und ist doch
schön dass sie das hier mal aufrufen und
wir jetzt wirklich auch da nochmal stück
für stück durchgehen können
entlastungspaket ja wir lernen alle noch
was hier miteinander
123 und auch vieles was gar nicht in
paketen gedacht wird wir haben wirklich
jede menge auf den weg gebracht wir
werden zum ersten juli die eeg-umlage
abschaffen
heizkostenzuschuss gibt es für die es
gibt so vorzustellen sie von der fdp da
gibt es überhaupt keine produktiven
zuschlägen hören sie jetzt bitte auch
mal wozu also nein
wir haben ein entlastungspaket auf den
weg gebracht wir haben ein zweites auf
den weg gebracht wo wir wirklich auch
verkehrsbund
übergreifend von der tankstelle bis zum
pnv heute ist die lesung auch für das
neue euro ticket wir gucken eben nicht
die eine maßnahme die gerade das leben
teurer macht sondern inflation ist ja
ein warenkorb da sind ja mal ein paar
dinge drin und da gibt es jetzt auch
nicht die eine lösung und das eine was
wir tun können und in diesen zeiten ist
doch auch mal ein kühler kopf vielleicht
ganz angemessen wir können immer
natürlich abdämpfen stoß federn aber wir
müssen ja auch mal an die wurzel von
problemen
[Applaus]
jetzt konzentrieren wir uns noch einmal
kurz auf die debatte ich wusste gar
nicht dass sie hier auch somit aktiv
sind wir haben entlastungs paket auf den
weg gebracht wir wollen aber an die
wurzel des problems die wurzel des
problems bedeutet natürlich auch zu
schauen warum märkte preise obwohl sich
rohölpreise gar nicht steigern an der
tankstelle weitergeben dass wir schnell
weg kommen von neben den fossilen
energieträgern die knapp sind und
neben diesen entlastungs paketen die
primär auf die bürgerinnen und bürger
einzahlen wir haben da natürlich jetzt
auch was für die unternehmen auf den weg
gebracht und das erste die kfw kredite
sind am montag gestartet die
bürgschaften letzte woche wir haben
neben den krediten aber auch die
möglichkeiten des temporary kreis des
frameworks genutzt also zuschüsse weil
viele unternehmen eben auch nicht mehr
in der lage sind noch mehr kredite und
noch mehr kredite aufzunehmen die
langfristigkeit
[Applaus]
langfristig agieren bedeutet aber auch
und der kollege schrodi aus dem
finanzbereich mutter gleich nochmal
darauf eingehen wir haben auch
steuerentlastungen die rückwirkend
greifen werden ab dem ersten januar in
dem wir freibeträge erhöhen wir werden
auch ansbach für kranke in ihrem antrag
schreiben sie auf was es mit den
studierenden bafög heute erste novelle
endlich mal wieder nötig dass da auch
was vorangeht für die studierenden in
diesem land
und die pakete sind stoßdämpfern wir
haben
wir haben die inflation hat verschiedene
facetten
die inflation kommt aus der energie aber
sie kommt auch aus den verschiedenen
anderen warengruppen die jetzt eben auch
steigen und ich will jetzt hier mal noch
zum abschluss einen satz sagen ihr
antrag liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aus der union das ist ein
gemischtwarenladen an ich wünsche mir
mal was und wenn ich jetzt nein sage wir
müssen mehr entlasten wir müssen auch
die steuer noch mehr senken aber bitte
halten wir doch mal die schuldenbremse
ein das ist doch widersprüchlich par
excellence und deswegen wie beamte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
gute dinge auf den weg gebracht heute
wird in 15 stunden viel beraten und
deswegen lehnen wir aber gleich diesen
antrag ab und ich freue mich noch über
gewinnbringende argumente in dieser doch
sehr hitzigen debatte vielen herzlichen
dank
verena hubert für die spd-fraktion wo
sie stellvertretende vorsitzende ist
verweist auf die entlassungs pakete die
die koalition beziehungsweise gehen dass
regierung schon vorgelegt haben unter
anderem heute am frühen abend das
steuerentlastungsgesetz
2022 im bundestag abschließend auf dem
programm und jetzt kein gottschalk für
die afg
ist wirklich wirksamer als die ampel
treten sie zurück dass wir schon mal
general rezept für dieses land zweitens
liebe kollegen von der cdu/csu leiden
sie eigentlich ein kollektive amnesie
die pendlerpauschale haben sie seit 2004
nicht angefasst da gab es sogar noch
sozial demokratische beteiligung wir
haben den tarif auf rädern angeboten
sachargument die co2 abgabe ist von
ihnen mitgetragen worden der heizung
über kopf ausstieg aus der atomkraft von
ihrer schuldenkönigin und kanzlerin
merkel und euro-rettung und schulden und
negativ cent auf
verehrter kollegen der cdu csu das ist
ja geradezu schlägt dem fass den boden
aus vertreibt kollege meister ich
schätze sie aber wie können sie so eine
rede halten nach das 16 jahren
regierungskoalition meine damen und
herren
leider im vorliegenden antrag kommen wir
zu den sachargumenten bild nicht einer
ihrer sieben punkte begründet man hat ja
wohl auf die schnelle tatsächlich die
populismus machen wollen oder vielleicht
weil sie in der kirche und wollen jetzt
buße tun die einzige partei die seit
fünf jahren hier im hause etwas gegen
inflation euro-rettung und negativzins
bringt und dort hat ist die hft fraktion
meine damen und herren und das gehört
entweder in und wähler den anger wie
gesagt sie sind die lösung nicht
alles was in diesem antrag zu lesen ist
kritisieren wir seit jahren und ich darf
mit erlaubnis der präsidentin aus der
welt vom 30 august 20 21 zitieren das
sozialpolitische erbe der kanzlerin sind
vor allem schulden also herr meister
auch der satz eben mit den 300
milliarden da sollten sie in sack und
asche gehen noch interessanter wird es
allerdings wenn du uns die gegenwärtige
ezb-politik einmal anschauen denn die
ist nicht nur angemessen sie ist aus
unserer sicht und auch da prozessieren
wir frau kollegin weil wir sie für
rechtswidrig und mit der verfassung
nicht vereinbar halten meine damen und
herren und auch hier in gedanken zu ende
zu bringen einmal die aktuelle
geldpolitik der ezb mit whatever it
takes von herrn draghi bord rwe tags der
satz heißt inflation dem hier und unsere
sparen und sparer die rentner und die
ärmeren und mittleren einkommen in
deutschland jetzt bezahlen das ist das
erbe von herrn draghi gleichzeitig meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]
und die kalte progression die wir hier
mit dem tarif auf rädern und werden ihn
wieder bei gestellt und herr lindner
auch da haben sie haben die sie ihre
partei hat das noch im wahlprogramm
stehen haben wir hier mehrmals
eingebracht das erste mal am 13 februar
2009 10 und als wir am 17 februar 22 im
hohen hause zum thema debattiert über
unseren antrag wurde auch einst mehr als
deutlich die er linkeren fraktion bei
uns hier im hause den gefällt es sogar
dass für die kalte progression hansi
will lieber und das ist eben in ihrer
rede auch klar geworden neue um
verteilungsmechanismen erfinden um das
geld nach ihrem gutdünken und das ist
das gefährliche hin zu verteilen und wer
dem kollegen schrodi in dieser debatte
aufmerksam zugehört hat wird bemerkt
haben dass er große lust hat gerade für
höhere einkommen die kalte progression
oder zum besseren teil gar nicht
abzuschaffen meine damen heimliche
steuererhöhungen durch die kalte
progression küche das ist ihr rezept
aber es trifft alle menschen in diesem
land grad kalte progression das ist
wissenschaftlich belegt trifft die
anderen menschen meine damen und herren
und genau wegen solchen politischen
handelns oder vielmehr nicht handelns
gibt es länder auf der welt wie
beispielsweise die schweiz die die
automatische beseitigung der kalten
progression in ihrer verfassung
geschrieben haben und meine kollegen von
der cdu das wäre ein argument unseren
tarif auf rädern doch nur endlich
zuzustimmen die schweiz als musterland
der demokratie das mit gutem grunde
wahrscheinlich in ihrer verfassung
hineinschreibt und sagen wir mal den
doch etwas ausgaben freudigen händen der
politik entzieht dann ist das ein guter
grund und herr kollege butting in der
schweiz dem land das eben als vorbild
sieht da antwortet auf die frage jetzt
von der letzten debatte kommen sie mit
ins boot und stimmen sie unserem antrag
dem tarif auf rädern bitte zu und ich
habe im übrigen auch nicht vernommen
dass in der schweiz debattiert wird die
verfassung zu ändern weil dieser
automatismus so gefährlich wäre falls ja
das königsrecht des haushaltes ist und
ein kurzes argument noch in richtung fdp
ich habe es eben schon erwähnt es wäre
ihre verantwortung gewesen herr lindner
diese krabbelgruppe von experimentier
gruppe bestehend aus grünen und spd
wieder auf den finanzpolitischen
richtigen pfad zu bringen schauen sie in
ihr wahlprogramm dort steht der tarif
auf rädern noch drehen entlasten sie die
menschen wirklich und hören sie auf mit
diesen link sozialistischen experimenten
meine damen und herren und liebe
wählerinnen und wähler in nrw wählen sie
die partei die für sie da ist und das
jahr stehe und keine an
bei gottschalk finanzpolitischer
sprecher der fraktion und ihm wird jetzt
folgen einer finanzpolitische sprecherin
und zwar katharina weg aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und bei diesem so wichtigen
thema für uns alle in diesem land auch
liebe bürgerinnen und bürgern
immer aber ansonsten ist das auch
manchmal einen debatten raum einfach
hier um uns über unsere gesetzesvorhaben
auszutauschen aber das geht uns wirklich
alle an und danke auch an die cdu csu
fraktion dass sie das bei diesen
prominenten dieser prominenten uhrzeit
aufgesetzt haben
73 prozent
eine relativ abstrakt wirken bezahlt
und diese zahl materialisiert sich
gerade bei uns allen im alltag ich weiß
nicht ob sie sich erinnern an die
tagesthemen das bild so alina mut das
brötchen da hatte wo einzelne produkte
sogar bei über 40 prozent erhöht waren
gurken tomaten wie teuer das alles
geworden ist im alltag der menschen ist
diese installation umfasst areal
unfassbar hoch gestern habe ich mit
einigen jungen eltern gesprochen die in
ruhla fangen wollen endlich nach der
korona krise und das häuschen oder den
zelt sogar an der ostsee weht sich gar
nicht leisten können wir haben schon
super lange und das ist auch ein
essenzieller teil des punktes den ich
heute machen möchte strukturelle
probleme das sieht man beispielsweise
auch im immobilien und im wohnbereich
diese preise sind schon lange hoch und
in der welt energiebereich das haben wir
gerade eben besprochen ist das thema
wirklich groß wir haben es jetzt an den
zapfsäulen und wir haben es auch im
nächsten jahr spätestens auf unseren
heizkosten rechnungen und das ist
wichtig
wir haben akut wirkliche probleme aber
wir müssen auch strukturell an die
probleme herangehen und da greift ihre
problemanalyse der reinen geldpolitik
ein fast zu kurz
ja
die zentralbank sollte agieren das ist
aber ihre rechtlich verbrieft und
richtige unabhängigkeit die zentralbank
ist für preisstabilität da
und ich wundere mich manchmal weil sie
sich ja so als wirtschaftspartei
darstellen kreisel entstehen doch durch
angebot und nachfrage
das wissen wir und wir haben wirklich
große probleme die jetzt auch noch als
externe schocks hinzukommen wir haben
beispielsweise der ukraine und in
russland krieg den sie überhaupt nicht
erwähnen und wir haben damit
zusammenhängende energieprobleme
ernährungsprobleme und diese
energieprobleme die sind doch
strukturell ich weiß nicht in welchem
wirtschaftsbereich sie unterwegs sind
aber wir waren es 55 prozent abhängig
von einem einzigen lieferanten
ich bin ja finanzpolitikerin wenn ich
ihn vor gestalten würde wohl ein titel
55 prozent ausmachen würde der würde
überhaupt gekauft weil das risikoprofil
so schlecht ist und das haben sie uns
leider verehrt die beta mit
wir müssen jetzt und ich bin dieser
regierung in ihrer gänze sehr dankbar
dass sie diese kluge wirtschafts und
energiepolitik mitträgt mit aller kraft
diversifizierung dient das angebot bei
der energie wir haben es geschafft von
55 prozent auf 35 prozent abhängigkeit
von gas schon runter zu kommen in einer
kraftanstrengung
und sie haben es in ihren 16 jahren
hinbekommen
die abhängigkeit um ein drittel zu
erhöhen das ist doch keine kluge
wirtschaftspolitik und wir legen hier in
den ersten monaten schon eine wirklich
kluge energie und wirtschaftspolitik vor
mit dem
und das thema ernährung
hängt auch sehr stark an lieferketten
aber auch an energie der größte treiber
sind nicht irgendwelche flächen prozente
sondern der größte treiber für die
getreide und in ernährungs preise sind
gerade die energiekosten und deswegen
ist dieses thema so wichtig und wir
müssen in der wirtschaftspolitik endlich
auch mal darüber sprechen was resilienz
eigentlich zu bedeuten hat globale
strukturen sind wichtig aber auch
regionale und lokale strukturen das
sehen wir doch jetzt so ergreifend und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier mit
unserer fortschritts koalition genau
diese kreislaufwirtschaft global lokal
und regional auch in europa denken und
uns zukunftsfähig aufstellen
gerade stehen vor den küsten der ukraine
große schiffe voll mit getreide die
nicht losfahren würden wir haben ein
riesiges lieferketten problem auch in
shanghai einen der größten
umschlagplätze dieses landes das heißt
es wichtig hier klug auszubalancieren
wieder global und regional zusammen
denken
leider hinterlassen sie uns in einigen
branchen auch dysfunktionale merkte ich
nehme noch mal das beispiel der energie
wir haben dort leider oligopolistische
marktstruktur
alles was wir dort drehen kann im moment
ist komplett in sicher ob das überhaupt
weitergeht neben werden kann an die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
auch hier wir stärken das kartellamt wir
müssen wirklich ich bin wirklich für
wettbewerb jahr aber verboten wettbewerb
mit guten rahmenbedingungen und das ist
das was diese ampel koalition endlich
umsetzen wird nach 16 jahren die das
nicht geschafft haben sondern uns
dysfunktionale märkte hinterlassen haben
wir haben frau hubert hatte es schon
gesagt natürlich akut
die entlastungs paket sind
denn wir haben einfach ein großes
problem dass sich menschen gerade etwas
nicht leisten können da rede ich vom
kinder sofort zuschlag ja dass man sich
vielleicht auch noch mal ein kinoticket
leisten können dann rede ich tatsächlich
auch von der energiepreis pauschale auch
vom 9 euro ticket dass man überhaupt an
die ostsee fahren kann das bringen wir
alles auf den weg wir machen
wirtschaftshilfen und sie gehen aber
auch die strukturellen probleme an und
das ist einfach unfassbar wichtig sowohl
für die wirtschaft unseres landes für
die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres kontinents
der in eine klimaneutrale und soziale
zukunft gemeinsam gehen kann mit guten
wertschöpfungsketten und dass wir es
trotzdem schaffen gemeinsam geben die
angebot und nachfrage strukturen in
funktionierenden märkten hinzubekommen
und
krümmels
somit liegt die zukunft
nicht nur darin jetzt akut abzufedern
auch da aufzupassen dass wir nicht neue
inflationsspirale sie hat uns
angesprochen ankurbeln sondern dass wir
eben tatsächlich die rahmenbedingungen
dieses einen planeten auf dem wir
zusammenleben berücksichtigen dass wir
darin gute wertschöpfungskette
entwickeln und dass wir gleichzeitig mit
denken aber dieses gleichzeitig die
balance jetzt die bürgerinnen und bürger
und die unternehmen mit großen
wirtschafts und finanz hilfen zu
unterstützen dass wir das hinbekommen
und da bin ich sehr dankbar dass auch
diese
innovative
dreier-koalition
daher jeweils bei ihren herzens themen
durchaus auch belastung ist ihr kaufen
rating energie ein auch da wo wir es
nicht unbedingt gewollt aber wird 100
zum wohle dieses volkes dieser
gesellschaft und europas und auf diesem
klugen weg auch mit der inflation
umzugehen freue ich mich gemeinsam in
den nächsten jahren dank
katharina beck finanzpolitische
sprecherin von bündnis 90/die grünen und
hier bekommen wir jetzt einen auftritt
in dieser debatte der ja selteneren
dafür ist die rednerin umso bekannter
sahra wagenknecht aus der fraktion die
linke
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ja die preise steigen und
steigen und sie fressen den menschen
einkommen und wohlstand weg selbst
mittelschicht familien müssen sich
einschränken und wer vorher schon mit
seinem gehalt oder seine kleinen rente
kaum über dem monat kam der ist am
verzweifeln
aber diese höchste inflation seit über
40 jahren die ist nicht vom himmel
gefallen und die ist auch nicht nur
ergebnisses ukraine krieg sondern sie
ist vor allem ergebnis eines eklatanten
politik versagen hier in unserem land
und ich denke wir müssen also
geht es ihnen nicht zu denken gibt es
ihnen nicht zu denken dass der preis für
den liter diesel
nirgendwo in der eu so stark gestiegen
ist wie in deutschland bei strompreisen
sind wir schon lange spitzenreiter und
trotzdem sind sie jetzt noch mal 20 mal
so schnell gestiegen wie in frankreich
und auch bei lebensmittel bei gas ist
das tempo der preissteigerung woanders
lange nicht so hoch wie hier und dem
wirtschaftsminister fällt dazu nur ein
wir werden alle ärmer werden nein habe
ich wenn preise steigen dann werden
durchaus nicht alle ärmer es werden auch
einige sehr viel reicher nämlich die die
steigenden preise am ende kassieren und
die gibt es allein im märz haben die
öl-konzerne hier in deutschland
zusätzliche gewinne in höhe von 1,2
milliarden euro gemacht 12 millionen in
einem monat und auch bei gas der seinen
doch vor allem die zwischenhändler ab
dennoch bekommen wir ja das billige
russische gas aus den langfristverträgen
das heißt wir sehen hier einige machen
schamlos
doch mit dem krieg und die regierung
schaut zu ich finde das empörend
und warum warum steigen die
lebensmittelpreise so rasant gleich zu
beginn des krieges gab es einen heißen
tipp für reiche leute wie man jetzt
schnell sein geld vermehren kann
agrarfonds das sind fonds die auf
steigende preise für lebensmittel wetten
und mit diesen wetten die preise erst so
richtig nach oben treiben und seit
beginn des krieges hat diese zockerei so
regelrecht geburt und ich finde dass es
auch völlig unakzeptabel denn die
rechnung dafür zeit otto
normalverbraucher der supermarktkasse
und das muss man alles nicht laufen
lassen und andere europäische
regierungen lassen es auch nicht laufen
in spanien und portugal wurde anfang mai
per gesetz der gaspreis fast halbiert
und auch der strompreis wurde gesenkt in
vielen ländern gibt es mittlerweile
gesetzliche preis decke für energie nur
der deutschen regierung fehlt offenbar
das rückgrat dazu stattdessen wollen sie
jetzt offenbar durch ein öl embargo die
preise noch weiter in die höhe treiben
und die grüne außenministerin lösung
unsere gesamten energie importe aus
russland auf null drücken für immer wie
sie stolz verkündet hat und auch die
union unterstützt doch das öl embargo
und teilweise sogar noch weiter gehende
forderungen und inszenieren sie sich
hier als vertreter des kleinen mannes
wie verlogen ist das denn
nicht
merken sie nicht dass die ganze
sanktionspolitik uns vielmehr als putin
schadet fällt ihnen gar nicht auf dass
der euro seit februar immer mehr an wert
verliert während der rubel inzwischen
sogar höher steht als zu beginn des
krieges da muss man doch mal darüber
nachdenken warum das so ist russland
kann seine energie eben auch woanders
verkaufen denn der größte teil der welt
beteiligt sich eben nicht an ihren
sanktionen aber bei uns gehen bei
explodierenden energiekosten
wortwörtlich die lichter aus und
deutschland wird wichtige teile ihrer
seiner in seiner industrie verlieren
wenn sich der kurs von frau baerbock
durchsetzt und deswegen muss man ganz
klar sagen herr bundeskanzler stellen
sie ihre ampel bei der grünen energie
preistreiberei endlich auf rot und
machen sie politik für die menschen hier
im land
sahra wagenknecht
linksfraktion mit ihrer sicht auf die
dinge
insbesondere was die preissteigerungen
im energiesektor angeht der nächste
redner ist markus herbrand und der ist
stellt finanzpolitischer sprecher der
fdp fraktion
zurück in deutschland sowie im gesamten
euroraum ist die inflation im laufe des
vergangenen jahres vor allem als folge
der krise sprunghaft angestiegen
übrigens sehr viel stärker als auch von
vielen ökonomen erwartet das liegt nicht
zuletzt daran dass weltweite
lieferketten gestört sind daneben wirken
sie steigt eine transport und auch
produktionskosten belasten aus und jetzt
vom selbstverständlich auch noch der
krieg zusätzlich hinzu keine phase es
handelt sich um ein wirklich wichtiges
thema die antwort der antragstellenden
fraktionen ist jedoch unseriös zum einen
deshalb weil sie alles das was schon
geschehen ist bzw augen wirklich im
parlamentarischen verfahren ist
unterschlagen und zum anderen deshalb
weil sie uns natürlich auch verschweigen
wie sie denn noch mehr entlastungen
eigentlich finanzieren wolle
soweit zum grundsätzlichen gerne drei
punkte konkret erstens suggeriert der
antrag dass dies dass der staat die
inflation quasi im alleingang beheben
kann sie gehen in ihrem antrag
fahrlässig unsauber mit der trennung
zwischen geld und fiskalpolitik um einen
grundpfeiler unserer wirtschaftsordnung
das wissen sie auch besser die ursachen
von inflation kann nämlich nur die
geldpolitik also die zentralbank
bekämpfen deswegen es geldwertstabilität
im aufgaben buch der ezb auch das
oberste ziel deswegen ist es maximal
populistisch so zu tun als könnte die
fiskalpolitik also der staat die
inflation voll beheben kann aber wie der
finanzminister ist immer sagt die folgen
abfedern und zweitens die ampelkoalition
hat innerhalb weniger monate so massive
entlastungen auf den weg gebracht wie
vermutlich noch niemals zuvor in so
kurzer zeit es handelt sich sowohl um
einmalige maßnahmen als auch um
dauerhaft wirkende maßnahmen und ich
muss sie mal auf listen das corona
steuer hilfe gesetz vier schaffen wir
mit dem cola steuer hilfe gesetzt hier
schaffen wir elf milliarden euro
entlastung mit einem
steuerentlastungsgesetz einschließlich
kinderbonus und energiepreis pauschale
werden den bürgerinnen und bürgern auf
die dauer der gesamten legislaturperiode
30 millionen milliarden euro
zurückgegeben mit der abschaffung der
eeg umlage werden unternehmen sowie
bürgerinnen und bürger alleine in diesem
jahr mit 6,6 milliarden euro entlastet
zudem satteln wir mit der temporären
absenkung der energie steuer auf
kraftstoffe nochmal 3,15 milliarden
obendrauf
unterstellt meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die eeg-umlage die wir
ansonsten konstant setzt die ampel damit
für den rest der legislaturperiode rund
67 milliarden euro für nachhaltiges
soziale zukunftsweisende
entlastungsmaßnahmen um die natürlich
die inflation abfedern
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen die
inflation
wird ungerechten kosten für energie und
lebensmittel belasten schwächere
haushalte mehr als finanzstärke die
finanzstärkeren teile unserer
gesellschaft deswegen adressieren wir
unsere maßnahmenpakete auch in erster
linie an diejenigen die diese
inflationären wirkungen härter treffen
familien bezieher von transferleistungen
aber auch eben diejenigen die eigenes
erwerbseinkommen erzielen und sich am
unteren sowie in der mitte des der
einkommensskala befinden wir halten das
für den richtigen weg und dritter punkt
vor allem in bezug auf die punkte 6 und
7 ihres forderungskataloges liebe
kolleginnen kollegen der cdu csu sind
zweifel angebracht ob anträge bei ihnen
eigentlich nochmal gegengelesen werden
unter punkt 7 fordern sie und ich
zitiere im rahmen der zur verfügung
stehenden haushaltsmittel die
grundgesetzliche schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten das muss man erst mal wirken
lassen in meinen augen im rahmen der zur
verfügung stehenden haushaltsmittel die
grundgesetzliche schuldenbremse
einzuhalten der tiefpunkt ist aber der
punkt 6 hier fordern sie allen ernstes
für alle eu vorhaben ein moratorium von
zwei jahren das ist absurd das ergebnis
einer solchen forderung macht meines
erachtens die eu gestaltungs unfähig
keine einheitlichen sanktionen keine
einheitlichen maßnahmen mehr zur
energiesicherheit keine weiteren
fortschritte in der außen- sicherheits-
finanzpolitik oder auf sonstigen
politikfelder es wäre ein faktischer
stillstand für die gesamte europäische
union es erscheint geradezu protest dass
ausgerechnet die cdu csu die eigene
kommissionspräsidentin entmachten und
die eu zur unfähigkeit blockieren will
dass sie sich offenbar nicht zu schade
sind diese forderungen auch gegen die eu
hier einzubringen zeigt dass sie
offenbar jetzt auch dem plenum an der
richtigen stelle neben der afg die
sitzen hoffe sehr dass dieser punkt ein
versehen war das zeigt aber auch das
beste an ihrem antrag ist die
überschrift herzlichen dank
markus herbrand der finanzpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion da doch noch
mit recht harschen worten am ende seines
redebeitrags hier zu einem antrag der
unionsfraktion mit vorschlägen wie die
inflation bekämpft werden soll die ist
die gegenrede möglichkeit ganz sparen
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unions-fraktion nationen ist stille
enteignungen sie frisst ersparnisse auf
die bürgerinnen und bürger bekommen
weniger für ihr geld das spüren sie im
supermarkt an der tankstelle in der
bäckerei
inflation ist zutiefst unsozial sie
trifft kleinere und mittlere einkommen
die hart arbeitende mitte im land
besonders hart
angesichts einer rekord inflation hat
us-präsident beiden inflation zu dem
top-thema der amerikanischen politik
gemacht top priority von dieser
regierung von diesem bundeskanzler hören
sie mir dazu nichts weder hier im
deutschen bundestag noch am sonntagabend
das thema das alle bürgerinnen und
bürger beschäftigt das geht nicht davon
weg
die bundesregierung diese koalition
dieses thema geht nicht davon weg dass
sie nicht darüber reden oder nicht
darüber reden wollen und übrigens weil
sie immer die 16 jahre ansprechen es gab
in den 16 jahren zuvor nicht einmal die
hohe inflation die wir hier gerade haben
handeln sie endlich bei dem thema das
die bürgerinnen und bürger am meisten
beschäftigt bei der preis bleibe
gespannt möchten sie eine zwischenfrage
aus der afc zweifel
wir haben einen sieben punkte plan gegen
preissteigerungen vorgelegt und haben
dabei drei ansätze das eine ist
kurzfristig die entlastung vor allem
beim preistreiber energie und
steuerentlastung energie preise sind
schon angesprochen worden und ja sie tun
was ohne zweifel wären darüber ja auch
letzte woche schon gesprochen es ist nur
zu wenig zu spät und zu bürokratisch das
ist das problem und deswegen schlagen
wir einmal mehr vor die steuern auch die
energie zu senken das entlastet in der
breite und in der tiefe die bürgerinnen
und bürger die es betrifft und wenn sie
dann schon die 300 euro pauschale machen
wenn sie an der stelle richtigerweise
entlasten dann bitte entlasten sie auch
rentnerinnen und rentner die studenten
die minijobber auch die leiden unter der
hohen inflation und die bekommen von
ihrem paket gar nichts ab und auch das
muss dann hier thematisiert werden und
wenn es dann heißt es müsste ich auch
finanziert werden herr herbrand dass sie
an dem tag an dem der finanzminister
rekord steuereinnahmen verkünden wird
bei der finanzschätzung an dem tag wo
klar wird dass ein prozent inflation
etwa 10 milliarden mehreinnahmen für den
staat bedeutet wir so tun als wäre das
geld dafür nicht da es geht darum den
bürgerinnen und bürgern vor allem bei
den energiepreisen das zurückzugeben was
sie aufgrund der höheren preise gerade
mehr auch bei den steuern zahlen darum
geht so dafür ist das geld ohne zweifel
auch
der zweite ansatz ist die preise sind
hoch auch weil die nachfrage höher ist
als das angebot deswegen geht es darum
das angebot zu erweitern und das ist
übrigens eine änderung in der
wirtschaftspolitik der letzten zehn
jahre notwendig geworden eben durch die
neue lage wo es jetzt darum geht auch
stärker wieder
wachstums angebots fördernde reformen in
den blick zu nehmen was produktivität
angeht bürokratieabbau im übrigen
europäisch wie deutsch können dazu es
gab schon gesagt worden das angebot wird
aber auch erweitert durch freien handeln
und wir haben das hier schon öfter
angesprochen aber ich will es noch
einmal tun weil das thema wirklich
grundsätzlich und wichtig ist wenn wir
mit einem start wie kanada
einen freihandel treiben können mit wem
denn dann wir können nicht nach katar
fliegen um gas zu kaufen aber die
beziehung zu kanada problematisieren und
wissen sie was der entscheidende teil
konnten auch wenn seine zeit kommt noch
das sagt nicht entspannen das sagt
winfried kretschmann der
ministerpräsident von baden württemberg
wenn er das so sieht liebe grüne sollten
auch sie endlich ist möglich machen dass
wir zehnter hier im deutschen bundestag
endlich ratifizieren können
und neben der kurzfristige entlastung
und der erweiterung des angebotes geht
es auch ja in unseren siebten punkt
darum die schuldenbremse wieder
einzuhalten ab dem nächsten jahr und
beim stabilitätspakt in der europäischen
union auch zurückzukehren zu den
grundzügen der zeit wie dieser mit
dieser inflation verschuldung frau
präsidentin gedanken will ich noch zu
ende führen verschuldung vor allem mit
der ezb politik verbunden eben auch zu
höherer inflation führt und der
finanzminister hat gesagt er will sich
in dieser frage der schuldenbremse so
das zitat im haushalt 2023 messen lassen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
kann ich ihnen zu sagen wir werden ihn
daran messen dass diese schuldenbremse
im nächsten jahr wie zugesagt wieder
eingehalten
jetzt
zwischenfrage von den ernsten lassen
möchten und von herrn ernst
lang ersparen dass sie die frage zu
lassen wir reden über die
preissteigerungen jetzt ist ihnen sicher
genauso bekannt wie wir das ein
wesentlicher treiber der preise zurzeit
die energiepreise sind
und sie haben auch richtigerweise
festgestellt ist eine frage von angebot
und nachfrage
jetzt habe ich noch nicht vorgenommen
von ihrer fraktion dass sie irgendetwas
getan hätten um energiebereich die
nachfrage zu erhöhen die nachfrage
wieder leicht zu erhöhen die man darüber
nachdenken ob die sanktionen die wir
verhängen insbesondere im energiebereich
er uns schaden die preise treiben auto
zu nutzen sind sie mit mir die
auffassung unabhängig davon ob jetzt
dass der krieg verbrecherisches brauchen
das ist unbestritten aber ist es an der
stelle nicht so das werden wir jetzt
tatsächlich dazu beitragen würden für
eine übergangszeit jedenfalls weiter öl
und gas zu beziehen das dass die
nachfrage eher erhöhen würde und damit
auch die preise auch sinken
entschuldigung die er das angebot
erhöhen und damit die preise auch senken
würden werde dies wäre das für sie eine
möglichkeit darüber nachzudenken dass
die stadt solche anträge einzubringen
die teilweise nicht zielführend sind
über ganz normale ökonomische vorgänger
die wir selbst ja selbst momentan ins
gegenteil verkehren von der wirkung her
ob man da nicht eine entlastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger hinkriegen wird
also ganz konkret gefragt sind sie der
auffassung dass über eine steigerung des
angebots bei gas und öl gegenwärtig ist
er nur die russen dazu in der lage dies
zu tun auch unsere preise stabilisieren
könnten also herr ernst das ist kein ich
ernst sein richtiger weise an der stelle
gerade der einwurf zuerst einmal beim
gas gibt es bis jetzt überhaupt noch gar
keine einschränkung des angebotes um das
auch mal klar zu sagen und wir finden es
im übrigen richtig und tragen das auch
ausdrücklich politisch mit so schwer
dass in der abwägung ist dass wir
schnellst möglich aber eben schrittweise
so wie es auch verantwortbar ist aus der
abhängigkeit von russischer energie
rauskommen und gleichzeitig gleichzeitig
aber eben das auch sprechende folgen im
landtag auch wenn sie in biologie
ansprechen die ideologie ist ja meistens
dann wenn man nicht bereit ist wenn die
welt sich ändert die eigene position zu
verändern sie die linkspartei sollte
endlich einmal das verhältnis zu
russland angesichts dessen was wir
gerade jeden tag sehen und vor allem
angesichts dessen was das ukrainische
volk jeden tag erleiden muss tod
verbrechen vergewaltigung sie sollten
endlich ihr verhältnis zu russland
klären bevor sich nicht nur fragen
stellen fest
sie findet immer noch die fünfte kolonne
moskaus bei allem was sie tun meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die rekord inflation ist das
thema für die bürgerinnen und bürger und
es ist übrigens einmal mehr die
unionsfraktion die die themen die die
bürgerinnen und bürger beschäftigt in
dieser sitzungswoche zum thema macht wir
erwarten
wir erwarten dass die bundesregierung
das thema inflation und preissteigerung
auch zu ihren thema macht dazu haben wir
einen sieben punkte plan vorgelegt
handeln sie endlich sie tun es nicht für
uns sie tun zu die bürgerinnen und
bürger
jetzt sparen war das stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion mit
einem kleinen internet somit klaus ernst
aus der linksfraktion und vor mir noch
mal der hinweis gegen 17 uhr 30
minimalwert es sich wahrscheinlich
verspäten dann heute im bundestag die
steuerentlastungsgesetz 20
priorität sie ist das absolut wichtigste
thema gerade für menschen in meiner
generation in meiner altersgruppe viele
von meinen
studienkollegen freundin wissen gar
nicht mehr wie sie ihr leben finanzieren
sollen die immobilienpreise sind ins
unermessliche gestiegen hat steigen die
lebensmittelpreise die energiepreise
steigen diese inflation ist
unverantwortlich unverantwortlich den
bürgern in unserem land gegenüber aber
sie haben jetzt die aufmerksamkeit
richtung beiden gerichtet haben gesagt
da hat es zur top priorität gemacht ich
möchte ihre aufmerksamkeit male auf ein
land richten das weniger weit weg ist
das ist ein land das nicht in der eu es
nicht in der eurozone ist dafür
vernünftige politik und direkte
demokratie hat das ist die schweiz und
während wir in deutschland mit einer
inflation von siebeneinhalb prozent
kämpfen hat die schweiz an der inflation
von lediglich zweieinhalb prozent und
das bedeutet irgendwas ist ja wohl in
der europäischen union schief gelaufen
und in europäischen union ist schief
gelaufen dass die ezb geld gedruckt hat
ohne ende diese inflation sie fällt doch
nicht vom himmel sondern sie ist das
ergebnis einer stetigen
geldmengenausweitung und wenn sie die
qualität gleich um kennen die man im
grundstudium mit der volkswirtschaft
lernen dann wissen sie geldmenge ist
gleich preisniveau wenn sie also die
geldmenge ausweiten steigt auch das
preisniveau und das haben wir über jahre
gesehen bei den immobilienpreisen das
sehen wir jetzt bei der energie bei den
lebensmittelpreisen bei allen möglichen
märkten und da frage ich sie da frage
ich sie herr sparen sie sind doch
mitglied sie sind mitglied des letzten
kabinetts gewesen das kabinett merkel
dass auf eu ebene von der leyen
produziert hat dass auf eu-ebene eine
christine lagarde produziert hat als
chefin der ezb christine lagarde hat
angela merkel als persönliche freundin
bezeichnet was kollegin des seinem
redebeitrag ausgestellt hat die
bundesregierung denn je getan war hat
sie gesagt wenn diese geldmenge heute
untergeht mehr allein so viele wie 2005
betragen dann werden wir das intro
edition hinaus sparen möchten sie
reagieren bitteschön
frau präsidentin mache es nur kurz weil
viele menschen machen die einmal mehr
das was sie hier immer machen eine rede
für facebook und youtube halten in der
sie sich wieder affären können und eine
mehr davon gemacht haben
s1 ist er richtig wie der kollege
meister darauf hingewiesen und wir tun
es in unserem antrag auch das im sinne
der geldwertstabilität natürlich jetzt
auch das mandat der europäischen
zentralbank gefragt ist aber in den
letzten 16 jahren im übrigen in einem
gesamtwirtschaftlich anderen umfeld in
der eurozone und in einem anderen
inflationsumfeld also wir können ja
gerne über die inflation von 4 5 43 21
jahren reden und auch in einer etwas
anderen situation ich bin ja ganz
begeistert dass frau weiter so abfärbt
dass jetzt alle fans der schweiz
geworden sind in der in der afd aber
unabhängig unabhängig unabhängig davon
ist es jetzt eben eine andere phase mit
dieser hohen inflation und sie macht
neben der geldpolitik in jedem fall auch
reformen und veränderungen in
deutschland notwendig und darauf werden
wir weiterhin hinweisen
jetzt sprach noch mal mit einer
erwiderung auf die kurzintervention von
norbert kleinwächter muss der afg
fraktion jetzt geht's hier im normalen
leben oder im regulären sagen wir mal so
den button verlauf weiter mit michael
schrodi dem finanzpolitischen sprecher
der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsident damen und
herren hier sparen wenn es eines
beweises gebraucht hätte das ziel ihre
partei gerade in einer parallelwelt
leben dann ist das ihre rede gewesen und
ihr antrag sie hören nichts zum thema
inflation von dieser regierung ich gebe
ihnen nur einen rat heute 17 25 wurde
dritte lesung steuerentlastungsgesetz 16
milliarden euro die man auf den weg
bringen um die auswirkungen abzudämpfen
da können sie dann zu hören wenn sie
schon nichts hören sie müssen nur die
ohren aufmachen dann kriegen sie es auch
mit stattdessen legen es uns hier ein
antrag vor mischung aus alten programm
setzen wenig tauglichen vorschlägen und
vor allem auf maßnahmen die wir schon
längst auf den weg bringen es braucht
schon sehr viel augen auto suggestive
kraft um diesen antrag einen hilfreichen
beitrag
zu der bekämpfung der inflation einer
preissteigerung zu nennen zunächst
einmal
die ursachen für die inflation
sind
importierte zu uns importiert ursachen
im polit inflation durch energiepreise
importierte inflation durch lieferketten
probleme durch die pandemie und wundere
ich mich ersparen gerade nach dem
wortbeitrag jetzt im anschluss über die
falschen und auch populistischen
vorwürfe geber der ezb die vollkommen
deplatziert sind in ihrem antrag meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wichtig
sind jetzt moment schnelle gezielte
hilfen und nicht bestenfalls
mittelfristig wirksame forderungen wie
sie in einem antrag haben wir können
gern über neue handelsabkommen sprechen
wie die jetzt konkret den menschen
helfen soll in ihrer situation das
müssen sie mir erklären das tun sie
nämlich nicht meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren die ampel regierung handelt
unerwünschten nach unterstützung dafür
für die maßnahmen die sie hier fordern
die wir über längst auf den weg bringe
ich sage nur sie wollen anreize für
innovationen investitionen wir
verlängern die degressive
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten im chor oder
steuer hilfe gesetz ich freue mich über
die unterstützung der cdu csu fraktion
sie wollen befristete energie
steuersenkungen gerade für benzin und
diesel energie steuersenkungsgesetz
nächste woche wird ich freue mich auf
die zustimmung der cdu csu fraktion sie
wollen die gefahr einer
lohn-preis-spirale entgegen würden dann
dürfen sie aber nicht vor allen dingen
beim hohen einkommen entlasten was sie
wollen dem antrag sondern dann müssen
sie gezielt diejenigen unterstützen die
unter den gestiegenen preisen
tatsächlich leiden die mittleren die
kleinen einkommen deswegen bringen wir
das steuerentlastungspaket auf dem weg
mit der erhöhung des grundfreibetrags
mit dem kinderbonus und auch mit der
energiepreis pauschale da übrigens
mustang
44 millionen
erwerbstätige bekommen 300 euro das sind
übrigens auch die mini cooper mit arbeit
und darin davon dass er nichts davon
hören es sind insgesamt 30 milliarden
euro
die wir auf den weg bringen und das sind
maßnahmen dabei die gerade auch dazu
beitragen dass wir mittleren kleinere
einkommen entlasten die da entsprechend
betroffen sind verräterisch ist da
einsatz in ihrem antrag das sagt ja ja
das tut er ja was kleine mittlere
einkommen das seien dabei aber ihr macht
es nicht in der breite was lieber meinen
ist wir machen es nicht ganz oben und
das ist auch richtig so weil wir an der
stelle ganz genau und wie sie dort
ansetzen müssen wo gerade die probleme
sind und das ist genau in der breite
nämlich bis hin in die mitte der
gesellschaft und da machen wir was dass
sie all ihre forderungen sind alle unter
finanzierungsvorbehalt am anfang stellen
kann ich sagen ist geschenkt für eine
oppositionspartei die muss es nicht tut
es auch ende aber dann steht das dann
auch um die schuldenbremse eingehalten
werden sollen sozusagen ist alles
finanzieren das geht so nicht so geht
nicht seriöse finanzpolitik an der
stelle herr spannendes wissen sie auch
ganz genau das wird ja alles
das wirkte in ihrem antrag alles sehr
bemüht aber sie wissen ja was es
bedeutet in einem zeugnis entschied
hatte sich bemüht ich will es keine
noten vergeben zu diesem antrag aber
hilfreich ist der wahrlich für ihre
überschrift nicht ein schutzschirm
wollen sie spannen ihr antrag ist er ein
fallschirm ohne schirm deshalb lehnen
wir den antrag auch ab
michael schrodi der finanzpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion zum antrag der
hier gerade diskutiert wird aus der
unionsfraktion zur bekämpfung der
preissteigerung da schlägt die union
eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen vor die
einschätzung dazu von michael schrodi
haben wir gehört jetzt die von bern
schattner aus der fdp fraktion
sowie der verfasser dieses antrages
gemeinsam haben sie sind in großen
teilen gut im anfertigen von plagiaten
denn nichts anderes ist ihr antrag eine
kopie mehrerer unsere eigenen anträge
aus den letzten wochen und monaten
nehmen wir zum beispiel die abschaffung
der eeg-umlage und die umsatzsteuer
absenkung auch für kraftstoffe sowie den
verzicht auf die geplante 4 prozent
regelung bei dem stilllegungsflächen all
das habe ich bzw meine fraktion in den
letzten wochen und monaten gefordert und
all dies wurde durch ihre fraktion
konsequent abgelehnt heute schreien sie
herum und versuchen damit zu kaschieren
dass sie für die meisten zuständig ja
selbst verantwortlich sind sie haben
doch die letzten 16 jahre regiert da
kann ich nur eins sagen großes kino alle
cdu
aber zurück zum antrag die kombination
aus hoher inflation einer einbrechenden
konjunktur und explodierenden rohstoff-
und energiepreise bei gleichzeitiger
störung der globalen warenketten ist
eine toxische mischung neben den folgen
der kroner maßnahmen und den gewachsenen
geldpolitischen konflikten und einer
seit knapp zehn jahren andauern und
katastrophalen geldpolitik der ezb ist
die inflation bereits im april diesen
jahres auf 7,4 prozent gestiegen
trotzdem verzögert die ezb die zinswende
weil die eu dieses phänomen nicht
überleben würde ein anstieg der zinsen
würde in den südlichen ländern europas
doch zusammen doch noch zum
zusammenbruch führen also opfern sie
lieber die ersparnisse der deutschen
bevölkerung und schauen einer immer
schneller werdenden verarmung der
mittelschicht zu
den wehren sich früher eine familie des
gutbürgerlichen mittel standen das noch
ein eigenheim bauen konnte ist es heute
für dieselbe familie kaum noch möglich
die monatliche miete zu bezahlen das
auto zu tanken oder im supermarkt den
einkaufswagen voll zu bekommen minister
hahn beck wenn sie den 3000 mitarbeitern
der öl raffinerie in schwedt sagen dass
sie sie nicht vergangen dann stimmt das
nicht ansatzweise sie vergaß er nicht
nur die leute dort sondern eine gesamte
nation haben sie den nicht im gleichen
zug angedeutet dass es durchaus zu
engpässen in der kraftstoffversorgung in
mittel und ostdeutschland kommen kann
meine damen und herren durch die von der
links grünen regierung erzeugt einen
grünen inflation ist es wahrscheinlich
dass wir bald drei euro mehr für den
liter kraftstoff bezahlen werden müssen
aber das ist ja auch ihr erklärtes ziel
weg vom auto hin zum lastenfahrrad liebe
kollegen der cdu statt unsere anträge
abzuschreiben stimmen sie ihnen doch
lieber gleich zu damit hätten wir die
bürger in unserem land bereits vor
monaten spürbar entlasten können vielen
dank
der kollege dieter janitschek hat das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen und die
der janacek ist wirtschaftspolitischer
sprecher seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin ist es gut
dass wir heute über dieses thema
inflation sprechen das wirklich viele
menschen draußen im land bewegt und auch
konkret trifft es ist aber auch wichtig
dass wir uns über die ursachen
auseinandersetzen und auch darüber reden
was wir als bundesregierung als staat
tun können und auch ehrlich sein wo wir
das nicht tun können denn wir können
nicht einen globalen angebotsschock
komplett kompensieren denn der
bundesrepublik deutschland allein
die europäische zentralbank hat eine
zinswende
angekündigt oder angedeutet die
wahrscheinlich im herbst kommen wird das
ist auch nicht die aufgabe des
parlaments darüber zu entscheiden ob
eine zinswende geboten ist allerdings
muss man auch sagen wir leben nun mal
einen externen angebotsschock sehr stark
getrieben durch öl und gas durch die
preise bei den rohstoffen bei
lebensmitteln und da stellt sich die
frage inwiefern geldpolitik gegensteuern
kann ein stückweit sicherlich aber auf
der anderen seite müssen wir natürlich
auch die wirtschaft am laufen halten
also ich wünschte dort auch glückliche
entscheidungen
wir sehen dass wir in große abhängigkeit
sind constanze stelzenmüller hat das mal
analystin vor kurzem gesagt wir haben
militär technisch an die usa
ausgeliefert wohlstand technisch an
china und energie politik an russland
ganz so klar würde ich es nicht benennen
aber wir sind abhängig und wir sehen
heute die folgen das echo von krisen
vergangener zeiten und wir sehen dass
insbesondere jetzt beim thema energie
dass wir einfach eine explosion von
preisen sehen die wir nur auf dauer
abfedern können indem wir entschlossen
investieren in erneuerbare energien
energieeffizienz und
ich nenne ich mal ein ganz konkretes
beispiel ich war letzte woche mit einer
wirtschaftsdelegation in irland
und habe dort ein neues wort gelernt
gewinnt reserve irland hat fünf gigawatt
bedarf kapazität von wind aber 70
gigawatt offshore an möglichkeiten dh da
ist produktion des export zu stabilen
preisen möglich dass es heute noch nicht
gestopft dass es bei den baltischen
staates auch so dass das europa der
erneuerbaren energien ist die eine
antwort gegen die inflation das ist die
eine antwort auf die inflation geben
investieren müssen aber natürlich wird
die kurzfristigen das will ich zu
gestehen die preise nicht lösen deshalb
hat robert habeck auch wie das getan was
ich mir nicht hätte vorstellen können
noch vor einem jahr nehme ich den
energieeinkauf zu diversifizieren so
dass wir davon ausgehen können dass
werden wir in wenigen monaten heute
haben wir schon die ersten ergebnisse
einen diversifizierten gasmarkt haben
dass wir dann auch wieder sinken der
preise sehen können sicher ist das nicht
so dass wir auch 2023 wieder eine
inflations rahmen reinkommen die
erträglicher ist als heute dass die
menschen dann davon auch wieder besser
profitieren können was aber auch jetzt
mal in ihre richtung zu schauen was ich
nicht so gern tue wirklich eine fatale
entwicklung war und den letzten wochen
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen ist die
entwicklung in china
die zero kovac strategie von präsident
lee in china führt dazu dass wir massive
einbrüche der chinesischen
volkswirtschaft haben dass wir
einbrüchen lieferketten haben die uns
auch ganz konkret treffen und auch das
können wir nicht aus der bundesrepublik
deutschland beeinflussen das ist etwas
was wahrscheinlich erst nach dem
volkskongress im oktober geklärt wird
wenn china versteht dass es falsch war
eine politik zu machen die dem eigenen
volk der eigenen wirtschaft schade dass
wir das besser gemacht haben indem wir
gesagt haben wir müssen irgendwann auch
mal mit diesem virus leben und mit
unseren impfstoffen die besser sind als
die chinesischen was können wir tun zum
einen konkret entlasten das haben wir
getan aber dort wurde mehrfach
angesprochen von der schule von
katharina beck dort mit der entlasten
nicht beim suv fahrer sondern dort wo es
gebraucht wird die union hatte eine
energie preissenkung in kosten höhe von
40 milliarden euro vorgeschlagen
schreibt in den antrag dass sie die
schuldenbremse einhalten will das ist
einfach nicht seriös mit verlaub das ist
keine glaubwürdige politik richtung
inflation und am ende brauchen wir die
kreativität unserer volkswirtschaft
natürlich sind hohe preise auch gerade
bei energie haben lenkungseffekte und
wir sehen gerade kreativität in den
betrieben die sich darauf einstellen wie
wir mit diesen lenkungseffekte umgehend
unsere volkswirtschaft modernisieren mit
weniger energie mit erneuerbarer energie
und mit den fähigkeiten die wir haben
auch modernität wettbewerbsfähigkeit zu
schaffen darum geht es jetzt in den
kommenden wochen entlastung und
kreativität zusammen dann schaffen wir
auch diese schwere zeit vielen dank
die italienische klar dass der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in der
debatte des bundestages zu einem antrag
der unionsfraktion mit allerlei
vorschlägen die die preissteigerung
bekämpfen sollen koalition die ampel
koalition verweist hier in ihren
diversen beiträgen darauf dass sie in
dieser hinsicht ja bereits eine
macht maximilian mordhorst könnt ihr das
unterstützen er spricht wie der fdp
fehlt die ernsthaftigkeit der inflation
die sie auch in ihrem antrag völlig
zurecht ansprechen will deswegen und der
kollege herr brandt hat das schon sehr
gut gemacht mal sagen was wir so alles
tun es wurde ja schon im einzelnen
aufgezählt aber dass man auch mal eine
gesamtsumme hat wir entlasten menschen
jetzt mit mehreren paketen um 37
milliarden euro ohne dass wir das so
geplant hatten das ist ein riesen eine
riesen hilfe für die menschen in
deutschland und eine große hilfe für die
menschen die von den energiepreisen und
von der inflation belastet sind ich
glaube das gerät hier gerade ein
bisschen in den hintergrund denn auch
das ist ja immer wieder ein punkt ihrer
kritik ich kann das alles verstehen aus
der opposition mehr geht immer und dann
macht man mal so eine liste ohne dass
man dazu im gegen finanzierungsvorschlag
hat fehlen darf alles okay aber sie
tragen in dem antrag auch schon wieder
ich will ja mal eine mehr auflösen schon
wieder die studenten und die rentner vor
sich her als würden wir denen nicht
helfen ich kann ihnen dringend empfehlen
hier gleich einmal sitzen zu bleiben und
den nächsten job noch mehr zuzuhören
denn dort werden wir das
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetz
verändern was sie verpennt haben in den
letzten jahren eine riesen häufigste
studenten in diesem land und ich kann
ihnen empfehlen auch morgen auch morgen
früh und 9 sie seien auch wieder
wunderbar spannend wir werden einen der
größten renten wir werden die größte
rentenerhöhungen der letzten 30 jahre in
deutschland beschließen das ist fast
doppelt so lang wie 16 jahren die sie
hier durchgehend in deutschland regiert
haben also zu tun als würden wir nicht
helfen nur mal in diesem konkreten paket
nicht diese konkrete pauschale zutrifft
während nur ein euro ticket
zusätzliche pauschale alles für die
rentner und studenten kommt ich glaube
das ist nicht ehrlich ich glaube da
finden sie den leuten einen bären auch
wenn sie die studenten und rentner so
vor sich her dran und dann
wir machen jetzt ich sag das mal ganz
ernsthaft den machen schulden und gerade
als zwei demokraten muss ich auch sagen
machen wir das nicht gerne waren uns in
einer außergewöhnlichen situation
befinden ich glaube auch das gerät hier
gerade so ein bisschen in den
hintergrund oder manche wollen dass
sogar relativieren
die oberste priorität hat die hilfe die
wir der ukraine leisten und da kann ich
mich um das eine oder andere wundern wir
machen ein öl an gas auch an kohle
embargo nicht gerne und schnell aber wir
machen ist so seriös dass wir den
menschen helfen und wir machen es
vorrangig weil wir die ukraine
unterstützen und war wer darf was
russland treibt nicht mehr unterstützen
wollen und ja das wird kosten haben wir
werden dafür sorgen dass das vernünftig
verteilt wird die kosten und nicht bei
den menschen die sehr wenig verdienen
oder in der mitte der gesellschaft
stehen besonders belastet wird aber auf
der anderen seite machen wir leider
schulden in deutschland wir machen
leider schulden in deutschland das ist
völlig richtig aber sie erzählen uns
immer wieder etwas und werfen es dem
finanzminister vor der schulden minister
und so weiter und so fort was machen sie
dann mit ihrem antrag sie werden das
geld mit vollen händen aus dem offenen
fenster und sagen den menschen nichts da
wie das in deutschland finanziert werden
soll das ist nicht ehrlich das macht
sich teilweise sogar lustig über die
menschen die belastet werden lieber ist
seriös machen mehr geht immer kann ich
gut nachvollziehen aber wir müssen nun
mal regieren in deutschland ich glaube
sie wussten mal wie das geht wir machen
uns jetzt vernünftig und zeigen den
menschen in deutschland wo wir ihn
wirklich helfen und nicht so wie sie das
vorgeschlagen haben vielen dank
maximilian mordhorst aus der
fdp-fraktion ganz ohne skript und ohne
zettel und ihn volk jetzt sebastian
brehm aus der unionsfraktion das geht
weiterhin um einen antrag aus eben
seiner fraktion zur bekämpfung der
inflation
der frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
ich darf wieder ein zitat des früheren
bundesbank präsidenten karl otto pöhl
beginnen dieser hat gesagt
mit der inflation ist es wie mit
zahnpasta ist sie erst aus der tube
bekommt man sie nur schwer wieder hinein
und liebe kolleginnen kollegen genau in
dieser situation befinden wir uns heute
und jetzt ist 16 jahre gab es keine
inflation jetzt ist die inflation da
deswegen ist es auch allerhöchste zeit
dass jetzt gehandelt wird und zwar
einerseits bei der ezb aber
andererseits auch insbesondere bei der
bundesregierung und wenn ich bei der ezb
bin dann ist es wichtig dass die
expansive geldpolitik und die
anleihenkäufe endlich gestoppt werden
und der negative einlagezins so bald wie
möglich verschwindet weil das reduziert
als das versorgen das reduziert
wohlstand in unserem land
aber liebe kolleginnen kollegen vor
allem die bundesregierung könnte handeln
wenn sie wollte lieber kollege studie
zum thema seriöse finanzpolitik
finanzminister lindner plant in einer
summe von regulären haushalt
nachtragshaushalt ergänzungs haushalt
sondern vermögen von über 300 milliarden
euro schulden das ist eine belastung der
nächsten generation par excellence das
ist absoluter negativrekord
eine solche neuverschuldung gab es noch
nie weder in der deutschen einheit noch
bei der krise 2008 noch in der korona
krise das ist absoluter rekord
und eigentlich wenn es nach christian
lindner geht da hat er die wichtige
debatte leider verlassen wenn es nach
christian lindner geht müsse es
neuwahlen in diesem haus geben ich darf
ihn nämlich zitieren vom deutschen
steuerberaterkongress am 25 22 yards
erst kürzlich in dem er gesagt habe
lieber neue wahlen als neue schulden und
daran muss er sich dann letztlich
endlich mal messen lassen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
christian lindner geht als
schuldenkönigin die geschichte der
bundesrepublik deutschland ein und
übrigens dass bei den höchsten
steuereinnahmen die wir haben bald eine
milliarde euro in 2025
es ist zeit die schuldenlast zu
reduzieren und zugleich spielräume zu
erarbeiten um die private hand die
bürgerinnen und bürger und die betriebe
zu entlasten das ist kein zitat von
sebastian brehm das ist ein zitat von
christian lindner und auch daran werden
wir ihn messen er tut genau das
gegenteil und die wahrheit ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die inflation
frisst sich ohne erkennbaren widerstand
der bundesregierung in die mitte der
gesellschaft und liebe kollegen deswegen
auch unser antrag das darf so nicht
bleiben wir brauchen einen schutzschirm
gegen inflation und der schutzschirm
besteht aus drei maßnahmen die jetzt
schnell umgesetzt werden können
inflationsbremse einführen mit einer
entlastung der kleineren und mittleren
einkommen und des mittelstandes durch
abschaffung der kalten progression
wir werden ja heute nachmittag auch
drüber reden im steuerentlastungsgesetz
übrigens auch kollegin nordost weil sie
sagen es ist nicht finanzierbar alleine
die mehreinnahmen aus der umsatzsteuer
im ersten quartal dieses jahres sind
über 20 milliarden euro und sie
entlasten vielleicht mit 30 im kleinen
kreis sie könnten wesentlich mehr
entlasten mit diesem jahr wenn man
nämlich die einkommensteuer
mehreinnahmen uns alles dazu nimmt also
eine gegenfinanzierung wäre es
selbstverständlich vorhanden wenn sie es
wollten möchten sie die zwischenfrage
von herrn motors zu lassen sind
verständlich
in vielen dank herr kollege dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen ich wollte mich
eigentlich nicht melden aber weil sie
mich noch direkt angesprochen haben
möchte ich zwei punkte machen also der
erste zu ihrem inhaltlichen punkt ist ja
völlig klar wir machen ja schon
entlastungspaket die eine gewisse menge
kosten insofern brauchen sie die summe
jetzt nicht so zu verrücken das andere
ist weil sie den bundesfinanzminister
angesprochen haben er befindet sich
gerade einmal in einem austausch mit dem
ukrainischen außenminister auch das
vielleicht zu den prioritäten und als
erklärung warum wir heute nicht ab oder
nicht mehr er war ja eben dabei dabei
ist
also zu dem thema entlastung vielleicht
lieber kollege mordhorst sie gleichen
mit dem paket was jetzt machen nicht
einmal ganz die preissteigerung von 2021
aus also derzeit wird die inflation 2022
in keiner weise in irgendeinem gesetz
berücksichtigt sie nehmen den
bürgerinnen und bürgern das geld ab weil
nämlich sie reduzieren durch die
inflation werde es einkommen reduziert
durch die kalte progression und durch
die negativzins wird das ersparte und
die altersversorgung reduziert also sie
nehmen doppelt den bürgerinnen und
bürger ab es wird zeit dass sie unserem
antrag zustimmen die kalte progression
die entlastung vorziehen und nicht erst
wie angekündigt vielleicht ein bisschen
im oktober oder november oder so weil
bis dahin sind die steuereinnahmen
wesentlich höher und die inflation ist
bei weitem nicht ausgeglichen und kommt
bei weitem insbesondere bei den kleinen
und mittleren einkommen in deutschland
nicht an liebe kolleginnen kollegen
die inflation ist in der breite der
gesellschaft angekommen aber wir werden
es heute nachmittag auch diskutieren die
breite der gesellschaft wird nicht
entlastet die studenten nicht die
senioren nicht die familie nicht also
handeln sie jetzt und stimmen sie
unserem antrag zu
da ist sebastian brehm möglicherweise
ein wenig zu optimistisch nächster
redner und den drittletzter redner in
dieser debatte zum unionsantrag zur
bekämpfung der preissteigerungen der
inflation ist paar samawi aus der
spd-fraktion
präsidentin die bag kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren wir sind
zweifelsohne in einem angespannten
wirtschaftlichen umfeld in einem großen
volkswirtschaftlichen stresstest der
viele menschen umtreibt und bei dem das
thema inflation natürlich eine große
rolle spielt wir haben es in vielen
reden heute gehört im märz hatten wir 39
5 prozent höhere energiepreise und 62
prozent höhere nahrungsmittelpreise
als ein jahr zuvor wie immer agieren wir
nicht auf einer insel sondern genau
wegen dieser entwicklung werden aktuell
in der gesamten eurozone
viele anti inflations und viele anti
stagnation schutzschirme aufgespannt um
im beet einem schutz schon zu bleiben es
ist wichtig dass die schirme die wir
jetzt bei regen und sturm aufspannen
wetterfest und nicht löchrig sind damit
sie ihren zweck erfüllen und dabei lässt
sich sagen diese regierung diese andere
koalition sorgt mit ihren entlastungs
paketen mit unserer auf dauer angelegten
strategie unabhängig zu werden von
fossiler energie
für stabile schutzschirme das hilft den
bürgerinnen und bürger und unternehmen
in unserem land deutlich mehr als die
löchrigen schirme die sie von der union
hier verteilen wollen weder mut noch
angst in dieser lage angemessen sondern
entschlossenen handelns macht die an
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wie sehr sie als union inzwischen
opposition und nicht mehr regierungen
sind zeigt hier im antrag dokumentierte
umgang mit der europäischen zentralbank
und da geht es mir gar nicht um ihre
populistischen neigung und abhandlungen
geht es um ihre haltung unter zitieren
wir doch mal ihren antrag sie schreiben
wörtlich
bestehen feste unabhängigkeit der ezb
das haben wir auch heute von einer dogge
meister gehört und dann kommt ein
bemerkenswerter satz dies setzt aber
voraus dass punkt punkt punkt daraus
folgere ich die union steht nur noch
unter ganz bestimmten voraussetzungen
zur unabhängigkeit der europäischen
zentralbank
ich frage mich was ist eigentlich los
mit dieser stolzen union die 16 jahre
lang das kanzleramt gestellt hat dieser
neue ton ist jedenfalls beachtlich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
in ihrem antrag der mehr sammelsurium
eine kollegin hubert sprach von einem
gemischtwarenladen ist als ein stimmiges
konzept sprechen sie davon dass die
ampel koalition nicht die breite der
gesellschaft entlasten würde das ist
aber ein ganz schöner unsinn wenn man
sich zum beispiel die aktuelle studie
des emk anschaut demzufolge finden durch
unsere entlastungs paket mit einem
volumen von mehr als 30 milliarden euro
zielgerichtete und in der breite der
gesellschaft
wirksame entlastung stadt wie folgende
beispiele zeigen
90 prozent der belastung aus den
energiepreisen werden bei paaren mit
zwei kindern mit einem
haushaltsnettoeinkommen von 2000 bis
2500 euro monatlich aufgefangen 77
prozent bei paaren mit zwei kindern und
einem einkommen zwischen 3600 5000 euro
monatlich 70 prozent bei
alleinerziehenden mit zwei kindern und
einem einkommen zwischen 2000 und 2600
euro monatlich und es ließe sich
fortsetzen mit unseren maßnahmen für
menschen die sozialhilfe grundsicherung
oder alg 2 bezieht für studierende auch
für die renten da die natürlich auch
autofahren die bus und bahn fahren und
entlastet werden wie zu 46 prozent zu
dem wohngeld empfängern gehörten damit
den heizkostenzuschuss bekommen die
stromrechnung bezahlt und damit von der
vorzeitigen reduktion der eeg umlage auf
0 profitieren von den hier auch manche
noch eine beschäftigung eine
geringfügige beschäftigung haben die
dann natürlich auch die
energiekosten pauschale bekommen damit
zeigt sich hier in unseren entlastungs
paketen sind genau die breite und die
mitte der gesellschaft und meinetwegen
die hart arbeitende mitte die herr spahn
aufgeführt hat abgebildet der
schutzschirm der ampel koalition ist
also überaus wirksam liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
klar ist unsere akuten maßnahmen können
nur maßnahmen aufsicht sein wir arbeiten
als ampelkoalition mit einer klugen
finanz und wirtschaftspolitik
bestmöglich gegen inflation und
stagnation an niemand können zum
gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt in einem so
unsicheren geopolitischen umfeld präzise
vorherzusagen wie die zukunft laufen
wird nicht in bezug auf inflation nicht
in bezug auf wachstum
wir sind daher daher weiterhin gut
beraten auch weiterhin vorausschauend
und mit bedacht zu agieren für den
moment gilt unser vorgehen als ampel zur
bekämpfung der inflation ist stimmig der
ehe unausgereifte antrag der union hilft
uns nicht weiter wir können daher guten
gewissens zurückweisen ich danke ihnen
erfurt hat der kollege dr klaus wiener
für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen der sebastian
brehm an zitat mitgebrachten des
bundesbankers ich habe auch noch mal
eins das hat nämlich weiter gesagt
inflation ist die spargel wenn man ihn
sieht ist es eigentlich schon zu spät
und genauso
fühlt sich an was wir hier erleben lange
zeit wurden die gefahren der inflation
klein geredet auch hier im parlament
noch im dezember habe ich an dieser
stelle von einer vertreterin einer der
regierungsparteien gehört dass es keinen
zusammenhang mehr gibt zwischen der
geldmenge und inflation und das
sondereffekte nicht überschätzt werden
dürften gewagte thesen wie wir heute
wissen
die ursachen für das aktuelle hoch
schießen die ursachen für das aktuelle
hoch schießen der preise sind bekannt
lieferketten probleme energieverknappung
und massive globaler fiskalische impulse
und weil diese faktoren zeitlich
zusammenfallen kann es sogar sein dass
die inflation kurzfristig noch weiter
steigt allerdings dürfte entlastungen
spätestens dann kommen wenn china seine
häfen wieder eröffnet wäre das dann ein
grund zu entwarnung ganz sicher nicht
zum einen und das klare ja auch schon
mehrfach an weil die notenbanken in den
letzten jahren unglaublich viel geld
geschaffen haben nicht nur die ezb aber
nur im euro raum beträgt die
überschussliquidität also das geld das
wir nicht zur finanzierung des wachstums
brauchen sechs millionen euro eine
unfassbar hohe zahl sollte dieses geld
einmal nachfragewirksam werden etwa weil
die kreditvergabe steigt dann muss die
regierung ihre inflationsprognose sicher
nochmal überdenken sie hat sie ja gerade
schon verdoppelt dann würde das sicher
nicht reichen aber auch unabhängig davon
sprechen grundlegende
volkswirtschaftliche entwicklung dafür
dass der preisauftrieb in den kommenden
jahren sehr viel höher sein wird als wir
das in den letzten 16 jahren erlebt
haben ich nenne hier nur die im trend
steigende co2 bepreisung stichwort green
fashion die rohstoffknappheit stichwort
china auch die neuen geopolitischen
blöcke die sich gerade formieren und die
zu einer regionalisierung des handels
führen würden und natürlich auch der
euro bei frau wagenknecht wenn ich das
sagen darf da müssen sie schon ein
bisschen länger zurück gucken er ist
seit 2012 150 jetzt sind wir bei 105
alle diese faktoren sprechen dafür dass
der inflationsdruck im trend deutlich
über der zielmarke von zwei prozent
liegen wird hört sich harmlos an ist es
aber nicht denn schon bei einer
inflation von vier prozent jährlich
verlieren sie nach 18 jahren die hälfte
ihres vermögens
200 negativzinsen ist das ein
riesenproblem für die altersvorsorge
was ist da ja zu tun vieles wurde hier
schon genannt wir müssen die
angebotsbedingungen stärken durch neue
handelsvereinbarungen liebe grüne auch
mal zeta unterschreiben durch
haushaltsdisziplin liebe fdp und durch
ein belastungsmoratorium lieber spd zwei
punkte liegen mir aber besonders am
herzen das ist einmal die
produktivitätsentwicklung und das andere
ist die bekämpfung des fachkräftemangels
wo es produktivitätswachstum dämpft die
lohnstückkosten wohlgemerkt die
lohnstückkosten nicht die löhne das ist
nämlich ein unterschied und bekämpft so
wirksam die inflation und was den
fachkräftemangel angeht so muss der
durch gezielte und passgenaue
einwanderung bekämpft werden und nicht
durch einen wie auch immer gearteten
spurwechsel
der inflationsschub
der inflationsschub das will ich hier
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen hat weder
die alte noch die neue regierung zu
verschulden er ist ein angebotsschock
man kann sogar sagen ein klassischer
angebotsschock die nahezu die ganze welt
trifft wie die regierung aber darauf
reagiert das macht einen großen
unterschied
ich kann sie deshalb über auffordern
schließen sich unserem antrag an um die
inflation strukturell und nachhaltig zu
bekämpfen und nicht durch eine reihe von
kurzfristig wirkenden einzelmaßnahmen
vielen dank
bloß wie ne aus der unionsfraktion der
vorletzte redner in der debatte über den
antrag der unionsfraktion zur bekämpfung
der preissteigerung letzter reden also
sebastian roloff nochmal spd-fraktion
und dann geht es danach weiter mit dem
thema dafür fließen dank verehrte frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren ich
bin wieder völlig begeistert sie
breitbeinig die union heute wieder
auftritt da zb die weisheit gepachtet
hätte und dann kriegen sie es noch nicht
mal hinten antrag vorzulegen der aus
sich heraus wenigstens logisch ist da
braucht man noch nicht mal
volkswirtschaftliche kenntnisse
widerspricht sich schon in den
wesentlichen forderungen beispiel die
frage der europäischen zentralbank diese
als zentral bewerten und einerseits
fordern die ezb muss unabhängig sein und
das ginge gar nicht dass da so seitens
der staaten rein regiert wird auf der
einen seite auf der anderen seite machen
sie aber politische aufforderungen die
politik zu ändern ja was gilt denn jetzt
unabhängigkeit oder vorgaben und der
antrag geht darüber hinaus
auch von völlig schäden nicht mit
rechtsradikalen sie brauchen auch nicht
dazwischen brücken
der antrag von völlig falschen prämissen
aus es ist in der
wirtschaftswissenschaft nichts neues
dass aktuell auslöser der aktuellen
inflation in angebotsschock es steigende
energiepreise probleme bei den
lieferketten rohstoffengpässe das sehen
wir ja auch alles problem sind nicht die
zinsen eher im gegenteil würden wir
jetzt die zinsen erhöhen wie der antrag
des fordert würde das bisschen
wirtschaftswachstum was jetzt
hoffentlich wieder kommt er ab gewirkt
es ist kontraproduktiv wenn wir diesen
antrag heute beschließen und dann nach
vorgehen würden und das muss man doch
verstehen und das muss hier auch gesagt
werden
außerdem ist es sinnvoll eine
angebotsknappheit zu investieren mehr
angebote zu schaffen im preisdruck zu
entlasten und was sagt da die union
haushaltskonsolidierung die heilige kuh
der schuldenbremse in schwedisch habe
ich nie verstanden
selbstverständlich müssen müssen den
guten zeiten haushalte konsolidiert
werden rücklagen geschaffen werden aber
wir haben eben keine guten zeiten wir
haben krisenzeiten unter muss investiert
werden
wenn einem das wasser bis zum hals steht
soll man den kopf nicht hängen lassen
ist ein einigermaßen bekanntes
sprichwort wendet man das auf die
schuldenbremse an es ist so als wenn man
dem ertrinken dann auch noch die hände
verbindet und er sich gar nicht mehr
wehren und agieren kamen dementsprechend
konnte man mir doch nicht erklären was
das bringen soll und wir sollten von
diesem dogma in zeiten wo investitionen
erforderlich sind abstand nehmen und
alleine in dieser frage ist der antrag
nicht konsistent das ist das was ich
meine dass es keinen sinn macht die cdu
möchte entlastungen und macht konkrete
vorschläge was jetzt zum beispiel mit
mehreinnahmen im steuerbereich passieren
soll ja ich denke wie sollen haushalte
konsolidieren dann können wir das geld
nicht ausgeben also wohin soll die reise
gehen so gehen wir auf jeden fall nicht
den richtigen weg bei der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit möchte ich jetzt
gar nicht anfangs deutsche
leistungsbilanzüberschuss ist bei 75
prozent die europa lässt 6 prozent zu
aber auch da
eine steigerung gefordert sonst sind sie
immer für obergrenzen da ist jetzt mal
eine sinnvoll die ignorieren sie
wirtschaftspolitisch also ich bin
offensichtlich nicht begeistert und bin
dementsprechend froh dass die abenteuer
der ganze reihe von maßnahmen einerseits
schon auf den weg gebracht oder
demnächst vorlegen wird regionale
transformations- und qualifikations
cluster klima verträge für unternehmen
eine industrie strategie
investitionsprogramme für kleine und
mittlere unternehmen stärkung von
selbstständigen und die initiative des
bmbf fachkräftesicherung zum beispiel
das sind die maßnahmen die wir brauchen
und auch beim bürokratieabbau oder bei
einem reformierten vergaberecht wird es
fortschritte geben zu den entlastungs
paketen ist schon viel gesagt worden ich
glaube wir brauchen darüber hinaus
weitere unterstützung der unternehmen in
der transformation da fällt der union ja
nur ein gegen in entsprechenden fonds zu
klagen das können sie den
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer einmal
erklären für diese hier sagt weiter sein
wollen ich glaube dass wir darüber
hinaus reden sollten die kurzarbeits
regeln auch für die transformation zu
verlängern qualifizierungsmaßnahmen
weiter zu fördern und selbstständige
besser abzusichern schließlich freue ich
mich und bin sicher dass wir im
bundestag rief teuren vergabegesetz
brauchen ich freue mich auf die weitere
diskussion der antrag heute hilft leider
nicht weiter vielen dank
sebastian roloff war das nochmal in der
debatte unionsantrag zur bekämpfung der
preissteigerung der antrag wird über
wiesen im ausschuss
zuständigen ausschuss weiter diskutiert
und wir sind schon beim nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt
27 novelle des
bundesausbildungsförderungsgesetzes
kurz war von 1971 wurde es von der
sozial-liberalen koalition eingeführt
jetzt schon die 27 novelle es gibt einen
gesetzentwurf dazu aus der
bundesregierung und ihr ebenfalls in
dieser debatte mit diskutiert wer einen
antrag der linksfraktion mit dem titel
bafög existenz sichert und krisenfest
gestalten mit der bafög reform soll der
kreis der anspruchsberechtigten
erweitert werden die gezahlten sätze
sollen erhöht werden vorgesehen ist ein
anstieg des sogenannten grundbedarfs
satzes von
427 auf
449 euro im monat das ist ein ganz viel
angesichts der aktuellen
preissteigerungen die wir haben und die
ja eben auch schon in der debatte
diskutiert worden sind aber die wohn
pauschale für studierende die nicht bei
den eltern wohnen soll von 325 auf 360
euro steigen von spd bündnis 90 die
grünen fdp die übrigen fraktionen haben
dagegen gestimmt enthaltungen gab es
keine
ich hoffe jetzt auf die
tagesordnungspunkte neuenahr und so dass
ich jetzt gesehen haben dass sie eine
kurze abstimmung noch mal stattgefunden
hat das war die frage was soll mit dem
antrag der unionsfraktion zum thema
preissteigerungen passieren soll er
heute schon abgestimmt werden oder im
ausschuss in zuständigen leiter
diskutiert so ist es dann auch gekommen
wird also noch weiter beraten werden und
jetzt sehen sie wieder große rotation
hier im plenum sie sehen auch schon die
bundesbildungsministerin bettina stark
watzinger die natürlich eine gewichtige
rolle spielt bei der reform des bafögs
ganz einfach weil sie dafür zuständig
ist als ministerin gibt es noch wie
gesagt noch ein bisschen
personalrotation weil die gefahr
politikerinnen wechseln und dann wird es
hier in kürze auch losgehen können es
gibt noch den einen und anderen schwarz
den rhein wie wir hier sehen
und eine geduldige bundestags
vizepräsidentin katrin göring eckardt
die jetzt allerdings ein bisschen
dampf macht
nicht folgen wollen den saal zu
verlassen
so
ich eröffne die aussprache und gebe das
wort der bundesministerin bettina stark
watzinger die heute ihren geburtstag
feiert zu der ich im namen des hauses
und alle anderen tun gehabt
ganz herzlichen dank das schönste
geburtstagsgeschenk ist dass ich heute
einen gesetzentwurf einbringen sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen viele junge
menschen haben dieser regierung bei der
letzten bundestagswahl ihre stimme ihr
vertrauen gegeben deswegen war der
auftrag klar das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung ist das
schatzministerium und deswegen stand die
reform des bafög ganz oben auf unserer
prioritätenliste
das bafög ist seit 50 jahren das
zentrale instrument damit auch
diejenigen ihren bildungsweg frei und
selbstbestimmt wählen können deren
eltern ihnen nicht finanzieren können
bafög bedeutet freiheit nicht der
geldbeutel der eltern entscheidet
sondern der junge mensch selbst war für
bedeutet chancengerechtigkeit vor kurzem
hat der berliner architekt francis kéré
den renommierten pritzker preis gewonnen
er stammt aus burkina faso und konnte in
deutschland studieren und was sagt er in
einem interview
bildung ist alles und ohne bafög wäre
ich heute kein dritter preisträger
millionen haben vom bafög profitiert
unser land hat davon profitiert jeder
euro für bildung ist doppelt investiert
aber wie
ausnahmen gibt es nicht die zeiten
ändern sich nach steuern tut not lange
ist das beim bafög versäumt worden daher
die dringlichkeit jetzt wir haben im
koalitionsvertrag eine strukturelle
reform vereinbart jetzt gehen wir den
ersten wichtigen schritt damit möglichst
schnell möglichst viele vom fortschritt
profitieren können 2,3 milliarden euro
sind für die reform in dieser
legislaturperiode
eingeplant
2,3 milliarden für mehr freiheit für
mehr chancengerechtigkeit das heißt wir
nehmen die nächste stufe im
aufstiegsversprechen denn niemand kann
sich aussuchen woher er kommt aber er
soll sich aussuchen können wohin er geht
[Applaus]
vorgesehen wir werden beides erhöhen die
fördersätze und die zahl derer die sie
in anspruch nehmen wir heben die
freibeträge beim einkommen der eltern um
satte 20 prozent an das erhöht die
reichweite des bafög deutlich
damit erreichen wir nämlich auch viele
bei denen das studium auf der kippe
stand weil die eltern zwar nicht
schlecht verdienen aber es immer noch
nicht reicht um diese erhebliche
belastung zu stemmen und auch der
förderhöchstbetrag wird deutlich steigen
nämlich um 8 prozent auf 931 euro wir
wollen die bedarfssätze anheben den
kinderbetreuungszuschlag aber vor allen
dingen auch den wohn zuschlag denn die
mieten steigen und die energiekosten
steigen deshalb auch noch mal außerhalb
des bafög der heizkostenzuschuss den wir
den studierenden gewähren
und wir wollen denjenigen diejenigen
unterstützen die später im leben sich
entscheiden ein studium oder eine
ausbildung
aufzunehmen und deswegen haben wir die
altersgrenze an auf 45 jahre klar ist
das bafög muss sich dem leben anpassen
nicht umgekehrt
dazu gehören auch einfache verfahren ich
habe mich selbst einmal an ein
bafög-antrag gesetzt und testweise
ausgefüllt das ging ganz gut aber dann
kommt der punkt an dem man ihn
übermitteln möchte hier müssen die
studierenden entweder ausdrucken und per
post schicken oder sie haben ein ausweis
mit einer id was man in der regel nicht
hat digitalisierung gut gemeint aber
schlecht gemacht wo sind wir eigentlich
mit der reform klappt das beantragen
dann endlich komplett digital wir leben
im digitalen zeitalter
nach ein letztes ist mir noch wichtig
nach 20 jahren soll es endlich leichter
werden die restschulden erlassen zu
bekommen ohne komplizierte
antragsverfahren das bafög kommt in
unserer zeit an flexibler attraktiver
und moderner
bereits ab herbst sollen die änderungen
wirken das ist ein anfang ein erster
aber er kommt weiterhin planen der
erstens das nothilfe instrument beim
bafög und für künftige krisen besser
gewappnet zu sein
zweitens die studien starthilfe wir